on May 12th 2588 The Entity known as SCP
ubu manifested in Kangas Greenland like
something out of the most nightmarish
Kaiju movie never made soon after there
was no more death but the world was
filled with such chaos and despair that
Humanity longed for that Eternal release
from its enormous stomping feet to its
cloa to its face featureless save for a
gaping grinning devouring mouth The
Entity was pure malice with all the time
in the world ubu decimated the planet
breaking the spirit of mankind and
raising every city to the ground in the
earlier days of ubu's invasion when
there was still dry land and people
still wanted to talk to each other
rather than joining floating islands of
Eternal chemically induced Slumber they
would commiserate about the shared
misery of the state of things oh UVU my
daughter hasn't spoken to me ever since
that monster shove my whole body down
her throat someone would say another
would pipe up trying to one up the first
man in sort of a trauma Olympics didn't
you see me in the news ubu carried me
around for a week snacking on me every
now and then like I was his own personal
Turkey Leg it was hell but honestly part
of me felt a little bummed out when he
threw me away yet another person would
chime in like veterans swapping War
Stories over a drink at the bar ubu made
me eat a pair of my pants whole thing
zipper and all then he decided he
thought that was funny made me eat pair
after pair after pair of them rinse and
repeat by the time he got bored I'd
eaten probably around 20 paars and sort
of got a taste for them after that
everyone on the planet had good reason
to despise
scpu but no one held more hate in his
heart for the pale Wicked creature than
Dr Lawrence mikal before the world was
turned upside down sometimes literally
Dr moud was a member of the mysterious
05 council at the SCP Foundation to be
specific he was
05-11 but that prestigious position at
the foundation couldn't protect him or
his loved ones from the wrath of ubu
when Dr moud was off duty ubu attacked
him and his wife first it impaled his
wife on a broom handle next it threw Dr
moud into an open pool of sewage in the
street then it bathed him in the filthy
water using his screaming wife as a
scrubbing brush all the while whistling
a horrible little bathtub song Centuries
after that awful experience as Dr moud
watched most of his colleagues give up
and choose the closest thing to death in
this broken world he became even more
determined to do something about it on
January 14th 3030 Dr moud abandoned the
scps naith and his fellow 05 council
members in search of the scps Corn CR an
abandoned craft to the southeast it
wasn't an easy Journey rowing all the
way there in a Lifeboat never knowing
when the Great White Beast would emerge
from the water and choose him as its
next unfortunate play thing he could see
the scps corn cek still floating there
until hunched but before he could row
any closer something collided with the
lifebo From Below snapping it in half Dr
macau's stomach dropped at the sight of
pale flesh but it was soon replaced with
relief when he saw that the thing that
had broken his lifebo was not in fact
ubu it was an injured narwhal behaving
erratically due to its RS the culprit
was almost certainly ubu it wasn't
content to just torment humans but
instead must have been targeting any
life form that could feel pain pain and
fear in his own words Dr moud had put it
at least a mass extinction wouldn't have
made it that personal after the life boo
broke apart moud swam to the conre
exhaustion and cold straining his
muscles it took him 2 hours to reach the
abandoned cargo barge and containment
site but eventually he managed to climb
up over the side and get on board there
was one very special thing about the
corn crate the thing that made it worth
crossing the ocean in a fragile little
Lifeboat to find every anomaly that made
the gamed list the list of anomalies
considered too dangerous to abandon even
in an apocalyptic scenario was contained
on the corn crake if there was anything
left that the foundation or anyone else
hadn't tried to use to defeat ubu it
would be on that ship after taking a
little while to recover Dr moud embarked
on an initial exploration of The Craft
all the staff were gone as he had
expected thankfully he still had his 05
ID card and it's still still worked like
a charm unlocking all of the automated
security systems on board a lot of what
he found was in Ruins but some things
had survived he found 10 hominid
replicators from SCP 2000 in perfect
working order there was a cage
containing the remains of SCP 2845 the
deer though ubu had done significant
damage to it SCP 319 a curious device
was there contained in a space locked
vacuum chamber this one was notable for
its potential ability to destroy the
universe he found a couple of safe class
anomalies such as SCP yez crowd control
for the Practical Optimist and SCP FNA
the portable warehouse the latter of the
two was a portable door frame to a
pocket Dimension he also stumbled upon
SCP 001 Last Ride of the day an old
Prometheus Labs prototype of a time
machine and possibly most importantly he
found SCP
076 the coffin was open but Abel didn't
attack Dr maoud he wasn't consumed with
murderous rage and blood lust the way he
always was before instead he was just
sitting on the edge of the ship silently
staring at the sea when he spotted moud
he gave him a small wave and did nothing
else the centuries of a world without
death a world without killing without
victory in battle had taken its toll on
him for possibly the first time in his
eternal life Abel was depressed 9 days
after he first inspected the corn CR mik
began to formulate a plan he loaded all
the hominid receptors into SCP FNA using
a thankfully still working forklift next
he was able to unseal the sealed portion
of SCP 001 Last Ride of the day and get
his hands on the details of the anomaly
it read SCP 001 is capable of temporally
relocating to its relative position
15,000 years prior to activation this
temporal displacement is Divergent
Paradox Irrelevant in other words a
separate timeline is created as a
landing point for example if an occupant
from timeline X were to murder their
parents in utero in Timeline y the Y
iteration of the occupant would no
longer exist but the occupant themselves
being from X would be unharmed when in a
fully active State SCP 001 deploys a 5 m
High telescopic antenna that functions
as a coloo wave energy sink essentially
coloo waves could only be produced as a
byproduct of the universe suddenly being
exterminated and ZK class reality
failures produced the most Colo waves in
one of these scenarios SCP 001 would be
able to use these waves to go back in
time 15,000 years effectively resetting
reality to a point far before the
catastrophe happened this information
allowed him to put his plan together to
resurrect project Beluga step one plant
explosive charges around scp3 19 step
two hide anything potentially useful
against SCP ubu inside of SCP FNA step
three get into the cockpit with SCP FNA
and toe step four raise the Colo sink
and step five blow the whole thing up 3
days later it was time to put the plan
into motion Dr moud placed the charges
around SCP 39's vacuum chamber there was
enough in place to implode the walls of
the vacuum chamber he closed the
bulkhead and began to deploying the Colo
syn 10% 25% 30% suddenly he could hear a
loud crashing sound the ship began to
tilt oh no he could hear the distant
sound of menacing Giggles the sync
reached 45 57 but as ubu grew closer he
quickly overrode the system to lower the
sink 45% 30% 25% 10% ubu grew closer and
closer and as it approached it began to
whistle the tune it once used when it
bathed moud and his wife in the sewer
ubu began to pound against the blast
door becoming increasingly frustrated as
it struggled to break through suddenly
another voice cut through the air an
unexpected one SCP 076 Abel called out
to maod encouraging him to carry on
while Abel held the Beast back as Abel
and ubu engaged in an epic battle maau
suddenly remembered something there was
an Express deployment module for the col
Co syn with no time to waste he
activated it all at once once he hit the
Detonator and then the year was
11,970 and the date was February 14th
13,960 years later the SCP Foundation
discovered something beneath a mound of
Earth and snow near the northern border
of Lapland Finland it was a shipping
container with a reinforced exterior the
interior of which could only be accessed
through a fortified bulkhead on one side
the words SCP 001 were written on the
side in black paint in spite of this the
object was given the designation as CP
848 a narrow winding tunnel through the
mound of Earth and snow was discovered
leading from the door to the outside
world the tunnel had significant wear
clearly having been used as a foot path
by someone but who well on April 12th
1993 the foundation got their answer SCP
848 bulkhead opened and a man stepped
out snapping his fingers and promptly
sealing the door behind him he was
designated po
8048 he was a 32-year-old man of French
Canadian descent answering to the name
of Dr Lawrence moud he made a series of
claims that the foundation found dubious
but noted it in the official file for
SCP 88848 just the same these included
but were not limited to SCP 8848 is a
time machine he held the office of 05-11
in the year 3030 from an alternate
timeline said timeline experienced a
modified Omega K class endof death
scenario that coincided with the
invasion of a tiok class anomaly known
as SCP ubu SCP ubu was an extremely
dangerous and sadistic entity who was
capable of among other things
neutralizing SCP 169 and SCP 682 his
timelines version of the foundation
launched project Beluga which resulted
in an impossible war with SCP ubu that
lasted 441 years Paul 848 deliberately
sabotaged SCP 319 to act as a power
source for SCP 88848 thus arriving in
Lapland in the year
11,970 BCE SCP ubu will arrive in
Greenland on May 12th
2588 Paul 848 was able to extend his
lifespan by sharing his Consciousness
between a Central Computer within SCP
8848 and several thousand bodies created
by his personal hominid replicators said
Consciousness sharing was achieved
through a book classified in the future
as P yez he wishes to assist the
foundation in the termination of SCP ubu
and has laid out a plan for its
termination as outline in document 8048
dzeta there were of course concerns
about the man's legitimacy but after
moud mentioned over4 specific terms and
data points known only to members of the
05 Council the foundation was forced to
take him at least a little bit seriously
a motion was filed requesting that poll
8048 be allowed to assist the foundation
with the termination of SCP p ubu as per
document 848 Zeta 054 voted yay 057
abstained and the rest of the council
voted nay the motion failed to pass a
follow-up motion was filed in response
requesting that poll 8048 be allowed to
assist the foundation with their own
strategy to respond to SCP ubu 05-10 5-4
057 and 05-10 abstained from voting the
rest voted nay the motion failed to pass
on April 14th 1995 Dr Isaiah Henderson
and Paul 848 sat down for an interview
when asked to State his name Dr mcau
also recited a mimetic passphrase that
when spoken by anyone other than 05-11
of past or present would cause them to
burst into flames the two men were at
odds from the beginning Dr Macau
expressed dismay and frustration that
his proposal was rejected meanwhile Dr
Henderson countered with the insistence
that macau's proposed plan was rejected
for posing an unnecessary risk to the
civilian public they debated for a
moment before Dr Henderson announced the
foundation's next plan of action Dr moud
was to be terminated the foundation
would proceed with its plans without him
at that point Dr Henderson terminated
moud as ordered he didn't count on one
thing though moud was no longer an
ordinary man bound to one body he hopped
into the body of a guard then into the
body of 054 to deliver a vital message
he had started this plan alone and was
ready to to bring it to a close alone
project Beluga would continue with or
without the foundation's support Dr
Macau returned to the bulkhead climbing
back inside and sealing it behind him he
had hoped to have the foundation behind
him he had hoped they would be allies in
the fight against the greatest evil
mankind ever encountered but they
disappointed him he had waited thousands
of years only for the organization he
devoted his life to to try and kill him
well he wasn't going to go down without
a fight this was bigger than the
foundation
bigger than anyone and no living person
was as equipped to handle ubu as he was
so he resumed project Beluga as a
one-man operation he issued a mission
statement which read as follows on May
12th 2588 The Entity known as SCP ubu
invaded and pillaged human civilization
for no other motivation than cruelty and
selfish gratification shortly thereafter
project Beluga was founded as a joint
effort between the goblo cult Coalition
and the SCP Foundation for the purposes
of ubu's Destruction ubu is not merely a
threat to human safety he's an affront
to every positive and loving Concept in
the human consciousness rather than our
lives he seeks to destroy our quality of
life to sa his own sick desires think
about it the taste of ice cream playing
with your dog the way you felt after
your first kiss that is ubu's sworn
Enemy No fate is too cool for him no
hatred is strong enough when project
Beluga Charter was signed 592 go
officers and Foundation staff were
present at this ceremony our troops
numbered in the hundreds of thousands I
Dr Lin moud am the only surviving member
and always will be what I lack in
numbers is compensated thousandfold by
my weapons my mind my replicated bodies
and eons of experience the following
record serves one purpose alone that
once justice has been brought to ubu
humans in The Shining golden ubu free
future will understand that one person
can accomplish through the power of hard
science and ra motion entwined in a
perfect and indestructible braid and
while we are at it you are very welcome
over the next several hundred years moud
worked to secure ownership of kusto
Greenland through a project Beluga
civilian front he evacuated the civilian
population from the area then spent a
century constructing a super weapon with
100 high yield nuclear weapons Heat
amplif ification runes a targeting
Beacon for SCP dag and five antimatter
Gathering pods from SCP H&M in place he
was finally ready for ubu to manifest
again boom on May 12th 2588 the town of
Kangas Greenland was destroyed by a
devastating 4 kiloton explosion
accompanied by a massive electromagnetic
pulse the few survivors that made it
through the incident alive described
seeing a pale green light in the area at
the time of the explosion shortly after
an omka class scenario or end of death
scenario began in which all
multicellular life on Earth began to
experience a regenerative effect
regardless of injury or illness in other
words nobody could die anymore this
resulted in intense worldwide panic in
the face of the inexplicable occurrence
as the Panic mounted the 05 Council of
the FCP Foundation held an emergency
meeting in order to address the
possibilities at hand meanwhile
civilians began reporting sightings of a
gigantic pale white humanoid monster
rampaging through their cities and
communities wrecking havoc and violently
attacking anyone and anything in its
path as the situation progressed and
worsened and the reality of the end of
death scenario began to set in the SCP
Foundation made the difficult decision
to lift its veil of secrecy and reveal
itself to the world 05- one made a
statement to the UN regarding the
reality of the worldwide anomaly
advising citizens to remain calm and
await further instructions 5 days after
the world learned the truth of the SCP
Foundation the pale monster arrived in
St John's New Finland where it was met
by mobile task force new7 hammerdown for
what they hoped would be a quick fight
and neutralization instead 2 years of
devastating bloody combat ensued by July
4th 2590 90% of the Task Force personnel
had been killed and Regen generated an
average of five times at this point MTF
news7 abandoned the city of St John
citing anomalously poor working
conditions after being held in place for
2 years the monster was able to break
through the defensive line and continue
its Rampage on October 10th 2590 the SCP
Foundation and the global occult
Coalition came together in an act of
unprecedented cooperation to found
project Beluga dedicated to the goal of
neutralizing the monster designated SCP
ubu and stopping its reign of terror but
project Beluga was unable to neutralize
the entity before it reached Columbus
Ohio on December 29th 2590 once it
arrived in the city SCP ubu began
dedicating its time to a gruesome
personal project first it dug a 2 km
deep hole in the city center next it
gathered a total of 2.9 Million
civilians throwing them into the hole
after the hole was full The Entity
leaped into the upper Stratosphere over
and over again stomping into the hole
each time when the people inside were
pulverized The Entity destroyed a large
Fountain which it used as a cup and
drank the resulting juices from the hole
this entire process took roughly 1 year
and when it was finished the entity
appeared to grow bored with Columbus and
move to Lake Erie upon reaching Lake
Erie SCP ubu trudged out into the water
and began assaulting the cargo ship
stock there it began lifting ships up
and throwing them out of the water some
flying high enough to exit Earth's
gravitational pole altogether two of the
ships were later spotted on the surface
of the Moon this chaos and destruction
continued for years and years until June
10th
2670 when SCP ubu was contained at SCP
Foundation site 59 however this
containment only lasted for 2 minutes at
which point The Entity escaped and made
its way to new New York City where it
was found howling and attempted to
defile the Statue of Liberty several
countries used their nuclear arsenals to
attack SCP ubu over the course of its
Rampage until this connectic agreement
was signed on February 10th
2674 cementing an agreement between NATO
Powers the Russian Federation the
People's Republic of China and the
global occult Coalition all signatories
agreed that due to concerns around the
environment any additional nuclear
strikes against the entity would be
prohibited after the signing was
finished SCP ubu crashed the ceremony
grabbing several lengths of rebar and 15
foreign dignitaries which it used to
construct itself a bead necklace the
next notable incident occurred when SCP
ubu showed up at site 19 interrupting a
round of testing with SCP AF a woman
capable of turning matter into stone by
speaking to it SCP ubu broke through the
ceiling crushing AFF beneath its weight
SCP 682 which was also present
approached the entity curiously and SCP
ubu responded by angrily defecating and
shouting at SCP 682 in gibberish SCP 682
seemed to understand this vocalization
and attacked SCP ubu demanding that it
take back the insult at this point SCP
ubu slapped 682s cheek causing 682 to
let out a horrific screen the slap left
behind a glowing green Mark which spread
over the entity of 682 body before
breaking the bonds of its cells all at
once dissolving the reptile into a pool
of toxic fluid SCP ubu then spent 5
minutes bathing in this fluid while
giggling after finishing its bath
devouring the reconstituted SCP and
screaming into the microphone for 20
minutes SCP ubu broke into armed
containment area 179 and swallowed SCP
2317 hole on March 5th 2686 SCP ubu
conducted an assault on Thal class SCP
2000 rendering it neutralized again
years of Hell passed as project Beluga
struggled to come up with new methods
that had not already been exhausted
meanwhile civilians did their best to
find ways to cope with the state of the
world on March 25th 2750 former film
star Nash deg grut published the zon
Manifesto A book based around a simple
principle life on Earth was no longer
worth living consciously and the only
way formed was to enter an internal coma
through the combination of chemicals and
guided meditation this kickstarted the
social movement the international zon on
June 24th 2790 project Beluga forces
managed to drive SCP ubu into the Bay of
Bengal where remained for 3 years
causing very little trouble aside from
underwater seismic events meanwhile the
international zon continued to grow and
one massive adherence known as cutopia
reached its goal of 5 million residents
on June Jun une 10th
2793 SCP ubu flung SCP 3000 out of the
ocean leaving it beached on the soil of
India several cities were destroyed in
this process The Entity then spent a
week pointing and laughing at The
Beached sea monster before grabbing it
by the tip of its tail and beginning to
drag it across Asia SCP ubu continued
carving a path through Asia the
wriggling SCP 3000 in tow until it
reached the bearing straight then it
began to cross the straight into Alaska
returning to North American territory
once more but it didn't stop there
instead advancing toward South America
until it and SCP 3000 arrived on the
eastern coast of Brazil on August 29th
2793 there it dragged its unfortunate
charge back into the ocean once more
disappearing from sight on August 30th
2793 SCP 169 or the Leviathan emerg from
the depths of the ocean there are some
reports that as CP 3000 had been tied
around its neck but these have not been
confirmed the Leviathan and SCP ubu then
entered into a lengthy battle which
carried on for several hundred years
after so much time had passed that
Witnesses could scarcely remember a time
when it wasn't happening the fight
between SCP ubu and SCP 169 came to a
halt much as it had with SCP 682 SCP ubu
slapped SCP 169 across the face with
force that its cell bonds dissolved and
it melted into a puddle of fluid which
was lost beneath the ocean waves SCP 169
was reclassified neutralized December
11th 3020 marked the start of a 10-year
period of inactivity for SCP ubu
ordinarily one would expect this to come
with a sense of relief however even in
spite of the global immortality the
collateral damage from SCP ubu's
centuries of Carnage had rendered the
surface of the Earth uninhabitable with
all land now underwater the remains of
human civilization persist on a single
archipelago of floating cities
constructed from ships and debris
meanwhile the international zon movement
has persisted gaining more and more
traction and popularity as conscious
life became less and less bearable an
enormous floating zon pile consisting of
international zon followers using
anomalous methods to achieve the perfect
zon began to form eventually this pile
earned the nickname new zland by May
28th 3028 the archipelago was abandoned
and the 140 remaining conscious humans
retreated to the SCP foundation's scps
nasmith there they lived in relative
safety for several months until SCP ubu
was spotted in the water off the port
bow of the naysmith on January 14th 3030
it emitted several sounds that Witnesses
described as mocking before swimming off
towards new zlin in response to this
reappearance after 10 years of
inactivity the 05 Council called an
emergency meeting the transcript for
this meeting reads as follows we haven't
exhausted all of our anomolous options
for neutralizing ubu where's the corn
crake we've been overseen sorence soing
the corn cake in this mess is only going
to it is anchored 57 clicks due
Southeast for why the hell did you tell
him that well friends it seems the Omega
K has had us up in about so long that
our personalities have run out of fuel
we were given from birth in all
likelihood we'd see better
professionalism and teamwork in new
zland as a matter of fact that's a good
segue into what I was about to propose
and frankly I hope you find the nicest
cleanest spots in the mass grave where
are you going that depends which way is
southeast at this point 05-11 left the
room presumably to track down the corn
CR leaving the remains of the 05 Council
there and leaving the remains of project
Beluga with the question of how to
handle
scpu according to its official SC CP
Foundation file SCP ubu is an extremely
violent and hostile humanoid entity of
Unknown Origin which appeared in
Greenland on May 12th 2588 it displays
anomalous physical strength and speed as
well as reality bending capabilities and
the emission of regenerative Lambda
waves linked to the ongoing end of death
scenario the appearance of SCP ubu and
the start of the end of death scenario
coincided with several additional
phenomenon there was a mass loss of
function for all the objects operated by
the three moons initiative the three
moons initiative was an extradimensional
human organization based in SCP
222- C or the afterlife known as
corbenic this organization was founded
14,000 years ago with the purpose of
establishing a human colony in the
afterlife and has long maintained a
peace treaty with the SCP Foundation SCP
2922 a method of communication that
allowed a human mind to make calls to
any pre-established phone number ceased
all functions next the extradimensional
space known as The Wanderer Library a
magical Archive of all the knowledge
from all known worlds and every book
that has ever been written will be
written and several that have not and
will not exist was SED from Earth when
the SCP Foundation pressed the Serpent's
hand for answers a representative
answered that irreconcilable security
concerns regarding Earth had come up and
forced them to make this decision a
representative of Marshall Carter and
dark limited somehow gained access to
the personal contact information of the
05 council's members and used this
information to reach out to them with a
business offer the company is ordinarily
on unfriendly terms with the SCP
Foundation due to their conflicting
interests namely Marshall Carter and
dark's interests in acquiring and
selling anomalous items entities and
experiences to the highest bidder
however in this case the company's
representative approached 05 council
members with a mixture of politeness and
Desperation begging the SCP Foundation
to purchase large amounts of the
company's stock the forest known as SCP
4000 lost all of its anomalous
properties all at once investigation
revealed only a small parchment note in
the area's entryway which read good luck
one of the most perplexing and
disconcerting phenomenon that occurred
concurrently with SCP ubu's first
appearance was what happened to SCP 3
2008 the infinite Ikea though this sort
of thing should have been impossible the
infinite Ikea was anomalously purchased
by some unknown entity the Ikea branding
was stricken from the building and it
was converted into an emergency shelter
all of these occurrences combined to
serve as a warning something big is
coming and indeed it was SCP uu it
appears to be impervious to most forms
of damage including blunt force trauma
heavy caliber machine gun fire
temperatures up to 1600° Kelvin
artillery fire and Direct Energy
discharge from other anomalies it did
express some discomfort when exposed to
severe simultaneous direct nuclear
strikes but it was not affected beyond
that the only recorded instance of
lasting damage to SCP ubu was on August
14th 2784 in which the entity bit its
left thumb seemingly for no reason other
than curiosity after biting its thumb
The Entity screamed for 7 days straight
then entered into a month-long crying
fit 30 years and 14 days later the thumb
had completely healed SCP ubu stands at
a height of 4.3 M while an exact measure
of its weight is unknown aemps set
measurement during its brief time in
containment showed that its weight is at
least
15,39 kg its exact anatomical
composition is unknown but a superficial
examination of the entity indicates that
its body shape resembles that of a large
androgenous humanoid covered in hairless
white skin similar in texture to that of
a dolphin or small whale The Entity has
no eyes ears or nostrils but seems to
still possess the ability to see hear
and smell its only visible sensory organ
aside from its skin is its5 M wide mouth
humanoid in nature with a prehensile
tongue of unknown length on its lower
body it has no apparent features aside
from a kowa that it uses to dispose of
waste SCP ubu is prone to vocalizations
mainly screaming laughing and babbling
but it does not appear to understand
speech in any known language nor does it
seem to be attempting to communicate
with anyone it encounters its primary
interest appears to be destruction and
causing as much of it as possible it
will attack anything that it can get its
hands on but seems to show a particular
preference for attacking and consuming
human beings in large populous areas
such as cities its demeanor is both
sadistic and childlike and it has been
seen playing with its victims for hours
before moving on to a new Target do due
to its regenerative effect present in
SCP ubu's vicinity it is incapable of
causing permanent damage to any living
thing and seems to have no greater
motivation Beyond causing fear and pain
SCP ubu is classified as Tiamat meaning
that it cannot be reasonably contained
at this time with the resources that the
foundation has therefore the focus has
shifted from containment to
neutralization which is ongoing via
project Beluga any and all non-critical
resources will be funneled into to
project Beluga as neutralization of SCP
ubu is a top priority additional
information on neutralization efforts is
restricted and may only be accessed by
members of project Beluga but in the end
it won't be project Beluga that defeats
this monstrous creature it'll be the
staunch efforts of one extremely
dedicated researcher when the sun rose
on that fateful day Jerry Marx had been
one of the lucky ones he worked in a
mine deep underground at the edge of a
small town in the rural United States
which meant he didn't see what happened
when day broke when the light of the sun
ravaged the Earth the first Jerry heard
about it was when his son Kyle came
racing into the mine frantically tapping
his dad's shoulder to get his attention
he'd run all the way from their tiny
Homestead under a fireproof blanket
thick and long enough to block the
sunlight from touching any part of
Kyle's skin his older sister Jerry's
daughter Carly had been so lucky caught
by the Light her body had turned to the
consistency of warm candle wax melting
into a form that barely resembled human
anymore Jerry had been one of a handful
of others working late in the mines that
day a few thought that young Kyle had
made the whole story up and ventured up
to the surface and into the light only
to me the same Twisted Fate the light
morphed their bodies into monstrosities
anyone in the small rural community
becoming an amorphous mass of human
flesh eventually those that stayed
behind in the mine heard the voices of
their loved ones their wives husbands
children all calling out to them from
outside they promised that nothing was
wrong that it was a lovely sunny day
outside and the Mine Workers should
clock out to come and enjoy it more of
them left reassured by hearing their
families that all was well and once more
none of them were seen again again only
Jerry and Kyle were left and it stayed
that way for several months the father
and son had to adapt to life underground
only leaving the mine to forage for food
and only while wearing thick dirty
mining overalls making sure not a single
millimeter of skin was on display if the
sunlight touched them they'd never make
it back alive venturing out of the mine
in his overalls Jerry had seen the
shuffling melted mass that had once been
the town's folk he did his best to avoid
it as he went house to house making sure
it never saw him while he raided
cupboards and refrigerators but he could
see it and among the Blobs of bodies
Blended together he saw something that
resembled his daughter it turned his
stomach not just knowing but actually
witnessing what had happened to her and
it was made all the worse on the days
that Carly called out to him and Kyle
while they hid in the mine it was
clearly her voice but there was
something wrong about it perhaps knowing
that she was a part of the melted
monstrosity made it easier to resist her
trying to coax them out into the light
it had almost been an entire year of
Life spent Underground when Jerry and
Kyle encountered their first actual
human beings since all the other workers
had left the mine the pair that arrived
were strange wearing protective suits
that covered them both head to toe just
like Jerry and Kyle had quickly realized
these two were aware that not even the
the tiniest hint of the Sun's
unforgiving light could be allowed to
reach them the two approached Jerry and
Kyle seemingly coming in peace although
the Father and Son remained cautious of
the newcomers making sure they were deep
enough in the mind to avoid the sunlight
at the Stony entrance the pair of them
revealed their faces confirming they
were still fully human before
introducing themselves as researcher
worth and Sergeant Booker of the SCP
Foundation sitting down with Jerry worth
explained what had really happened he
had been working for an organization
that contained and studied anomalous
creatures and phenomena the foundation
Booker had been a member of a special
armed unit within the same establishment
or a mobile task force but now the SCP
Foundation itself had fallen with a
number of its own Personnel turned into
more of the amorphous fleshy creatures
in the sunlight we spent a lot of years
keeping all this from the public worth
admitted sounding guilty but implying
the choice was out of his hands but I
don't suppose there's any point in
Secrets anymore it's the sound you see
Mr Marx you can call me Jerry he
interrupted sorry Jerry worth corrected
himself but something happened to the
sun it changed decimated the entire
planet in barely any time at all I mean
all those people millions billions all
at once dear God worth took a moment as
the existential dread of it all once
again caught up with him it turned out
the biggest anomaly was right above us
Booker continued for him she sounded a
lot more stoic even a little coldly
detached from it all SCP 001 that's what
the foundation called it is there a way
to reverse it or cure the people that
the sunlight you know changes Jerry
asked thinking of Carly you mean SCP 00
1-A no I I'm sorry Jerry there's nothing
we can do the researcher said failing to
sound as recomposed as he pretended to
be your daughter is gone but at least
you still have your worth paused looking
around at the mine even in the low light
there was no sign of Kyle Jerry turned
to scan the area to his horror his son
had seemed to have vanish while they
were talking instantly Panic caused him
to think that Kyle had wandered out of
the mine and into the sunlight turning
into part of what worth had called SCP
001 D but the boy would have had to walk
past Jerry to start heading that
direction plus the father knew his son
was far too scared to go outside after
seeing what the son had done to Carly
Booker had a tactical bag filled with
equipment flashlights spare batteries
even flares for whenever the power in
those ran out and both working and
living in the mine so long Jerry had
Maps knew certain routes through the
Deep network of tunnels almost by heart
between them the three had enough to
mount a search for the missing boy
keeping together they traversed away
from the first of several large Chambers
down into the dark depths of the mine
Kyle his father yelled his voice echoing
through the tunnel Kyle buddy it's Dad
you there walking behind him researcher
worth and Sergeant Booker pared the
calls assuring the missing boy that they
didn't mean him or Jerry any harm as the
trao walked deeper and deeper they began
to venture into a portion of the mine
that had hardly been used by the workers
it was darker than the areas further up
while those had rows of electric lamps
powered by long cables attached to
generators down here the only light came
from the flashlights the group carried
Kyle come on out Jerry called out for
his son again this isn't the time to
split up we need to stick together come
on son I'm really worried here once
again there was no answer just then
Jerry caught the sight of Booker and
worth out of the corner of his eye both
of them knew a lot about SCP 001 and the
mind worker couldn't help the suspicion
that added to his perception of them
after all Kyle had never run off before
now and Jerry couldn't help but think
while his attention had been turned that
the par Foundation Personnel had taken
his son dad a voice suddenly called out
Jerry's head spun on a swivel at the
sound of Kyle calling for him Dad where
are you it echoed through the tunnel
again that's him Jerry exclaimed to the
other two which way did they come from
Straight Ahead it sounds like Booker
replied hold on wor interjected I think
you two should look at this the beam
from his flashlight was pointed at the
rocky floor of the tunnel something was
gleaming wet against the stone a large
smear of red like something had been
dragged in the direction Kyle's voice
was coming from oh God he could be hurt
Jerry said urgently hurt might not be
the right word I'm afraid Jerry the
researcher said solemnly there's a lot
of blood here too much all the more
reason to go further and find where he's
calling from the father retorted angrily
that's if it is the kid that's actually
calling us Booker replied her and worth
exchanging a worried glance at each
other you two know something don't you
Jerry demanded does that thing from the
outside does it have my son too Dad
another voice called Jerry froze his
blood as cold as the M tunnel he stood
in he hadn't heard that voice in almost
a year but recognized it immediately it
was Carly his daughter it seemed
impossible he knew she had been merged
into part of SCP 001a when day broke but
now she was somehow calling out to Jerry
her voice sounded clearer like it had
used to before she changed and she
wasn't trying to lure her father out
into the sunlight either for a moment it
seemed to Jerry like his daughter had
somehow come back Dad we're both over
here Carly's voice called again we need
your help Kyle's stuck who's that Booker
whispered that's Carly Jerry sniffed
holding back tears you said your
daughter became a part of scp1 D worth
pointed out maybe she got better the
father asked hopefully I hate to say it
but that's definitely not her Sergeant
Booker replied we should turn back now
if there's an anomaly in these tunnels
that's not going to be pretty for any of
us she added turning to worth what Jerry
yelled what do you mean by that look
buddy those aren't your children the MTF
agent said bluntly it sound like SCP 00
1- got them no no the the voices are too
clear worth replied I think something
else is in here before Jerry could
explode with anger at how uninterested
both Foundation personnels seemed at the
fate of his children another sound Was
Heard footsteps something shuffling
closer pading its feet on the stone
there was a low growl that filled the
tunnel as whatever it was came closer
still dad the voice of Carly repeated
sounding only a few feet away now where
are you Dad Kyle's voice immediately
followed it behind came the sound of
Booker striking a flare as it erupted
into a plume of light and heat she threw
it down the tunnel and there they were
not Jerry's children but instead a pair
of nightmarish creatures they backed
away from the flare slightly the light
still illuminated their blood red forms
walking on all fours like wolves the
creatures elongated heads were missing
any eyes just Jaws filled with rows of
sharp Red Fangs dad came Kyle's voice
again emanating from one of the monsters
it was mimicking Jerry's son both of his
kids even having seen scp1 daa at a
distance the father could barely believe
his eyes 939 Booker yelled the second
her flare illuminated them run she
pulled the sidearm and open fire the
bang of each shot ringing loudly through
the tunnel the pair of 939 pounced at
her while Jerry and worth turned to run
back the way they had come as the
creatures attacked The Echoes of the
gunfire were replaced with blood
curdling screams what the hell are those
things Jerry yelled in a panic SCP 939
researcher worth panted too much to
explain they're pack hunters and they're
and they're vicious what about Kyle and
Carly I heard their voices that's what
those monsters do they mimic human
speech to draw us out we their pre
there's no telling how long they've been
down here they might have retreated to
the mine to avoid the sun on the surface
worth yelled the sound of the scp-939 is
getting closer we catching up right on
Jerry and Worth's heels why would they
come down here for the Mind worker
huffed slightly ahead of the researcher
given his slightly stronger physique to
escape the sunlight worth replied SCP
939 tap
Bri his sentence was overtaken by a
scream as one of the blood red creatures
caught worth by the ankle knocking him
down and pulling him back to be devoured
Jerry didn't look back he just kept
running back through the tunnel the
sound of SCP 939 calling after him in
Kyle and Carly's voices made it even
harder not to stop and turn even just
for a second but he reminded himself
that if he stopped running then he
couldn't lure the creatures out of the
mine and into the sunlight it wasn't how
he'd ever wanted to go out but maybe
that way Jerry would see his kids again
MTF agents scramble through the crowd of
bloodthirsty hypnotized Festival goers
up on the stage a pair of living statues
hold down a screaming man as they
produce medieval instruments of torture
from an antique case maybe this time the
agents can stop it maybe they can
prevent all the horror and bloodshed but
one thing stands in their way a
man-sized cartoonish dove costume flying
down towards them wielding a large
wooden Mallet that would only bring
death and destruction needless to say
even by Foundation standards this one is
going to be weird when you found
yourself sought out by the SCP
foundation's recruitment Division and
offered a role in the research
department they made sure to inform you
of the risks after all a workplace
injury in this line of work might be far
more serious than slipping on a wet
floor or developing carpal tunnel from
typing all day working within the ranks
of the foundation you could be the
unfortunate victim of any number of
dangerous anomalies whether it's scp096
appearing behind you after you
accidentally caught a glimpse of it as a
single Pixel in a photo or if you were
in the wrong place at the wrong time
whenever SCP 682 next broke out then
chances are you'd be receiving an early
redundancy and a closed casket service
if there's even enough of you left to
bury it is the one thing you never want
to happen the scenario you're constantly
warned about from the moment you join
the foundation a containment breach
anything can be the cause of an anomaly
Breaking Free of containment and
spreading Untold chaos in the process
whether it's the result of a
particularly cantankerous SCP that
doesn't take kindly to being locked up
an act of earnest human error with
disastrous consequences or even
International sabotage enacted by a
group of interests trying to seize
anomalies for their own purposes there
is no telling when or where a
Containment Breach might occur or is
there despite all the resources at their
disposal specialized facilities spanning
the globe advanced technology and a
nearly inexhaustible supply of personnel
to contain scps the foundation still
manages to suffer catastrophic
casualties as a result of containment
breaches but surely if they're so well
equipped such breaches should be almost
impossible right well yes so what causes
them what if every Containment Breach
all the loss of life the further spread
of anomalies and the destruction of
foundation property incurred was all
caused by an SCP not a living entity
mind you more some kind of latent
anomalous phenomenon that triggers
containment breaches without warning the
prevailing Theory surrounding this
phenomenon is even itself considered to
be an SCP within its own right referred
to as SCP 001 of course as many of those
while versed in the history and
practices of the SCP Foundation will
already know SCP 001 is a designation
shared by a number of anomalies some are
believed to actually exist While others
are speculated to just be falsified
covers created to mask the real SCP 001
from beings such as the gate guardian
and the Scarlet King to the existence of
God's blind spot and even the foundation
itself each of these SCP 001's are
nicknamed after the foundation
researcher who proposed them for the
designation and often considered to be
some of the first if not the very first
anomalies ever encountered or at least
documented in that regard this SCP 001
plague's proposal could well be one of
the very first latent anomalies to exist
explaining why so many scps were
uncontained prior to the foundation
being established and why even now with
all their resources containment breaches
are still a worryingly frequent
occurrence there are multiple anomalies
that appear to have been directly
affected by SCP 001 at least according
to the research of one of the
foundation's directors director leg
while he might be drawing conclusions
and seeing patterns where they're aren't
any to speak of leg reasons that the
circumstances of these specific recorded
containment breaches seem to indicate
that as CP 001 was at fault the first of
these incidences director leg focuses on
in his research is also the one we'll be
focusing on for the remainder of this
video it is designated as SCP
01-1 SCP 0011 previously went under the
designation of SCP 5770 it is an annual
anomalous event that occurs in the PIAA
Deora in Florence Italy the event
consists of an unscheduled Festival that
goes on for a period of 10 days where in
anyone present within a 10 km range of
the affected area suffers a mind
altering effect that compels them to
attend the festival however SCP 0011 is
not a well-documented
long-running Festival of great cultural
significance to the people of Florence
neither is it an event that is widely
advertised yet those who have
experienced the psychic draw of this
anomalous Festival are driven to
attendance during the course of SCP
01-1 two anomalous entities that
resemble the statues created by
Michelangelo during the Renaissance will
host a show where they take to the stage
to judge people they deemed to be
Sinners this pair of statue creatures
will call upon the audience and bring
those theyve designated Sinners up onto
the stage with them and will then enact
makeshift grueling punishments these
have been noted to resemble the acts
depicted in Dante alig's Inferno so if
you ever need any further proof of how
hellish these punishments are we
recommend asking an Art Expert the
moment that SCP 00 1-1 ceases and the
festival comes to a close any and all in
attendance are subject to yet another
form of anomalous mental alteration and
will proceed to instantly forget the
event any of the horrific tortures
performed on stage becomes unknown to
those that directly witnessed it leaving
them unaware of anything that occurred
only moments prior so given the
foundation's extensive knowledge of this
Festival its gruesome proceedings and
the effects it has on those in
attendance you might be forgiven for
expecting them to have a fairly
wellestablished method of keeping the
event contained presumably setting up a
cordin to keep attendance out of the
area administering amnestics to any that
might have been affected by SCP 00 1
d1's anomalous mind altering but then
you remember SCP 001 the theory behind
what could be the cause of containment
breaches as a result the foundation has
still been unable to establish
containment of the event formerly known
as SCP 5770 and director leg's research
has tied this issue with containment to
SCP 001 hence the festival's
redesignation to SCP
01-1 following the initial discovery of
an anomalous annual occurrence in the
City of Florence in
1985 the SCP foundation's head
researcher assigned to what was then
known as SCP 5770 was one Joseph Pasqua
former site director at site 322 Pasqua
was according to the incidents recorded
on the foundation's own database somehow
manipulated by one of the anomalous
statue creatures that performed the show
during occurrences of SCP 5770 it was
thanks to the influence of this entity
that Joseph Pasad deserted his post at
the foundation and went into hiding the
fact that the influence of one of the
performers of this Festival was able to
extend its influence to a senior member
of the foundation was not only troubling
but also constituted a Containment
Breach pasot would later be tracked down
by Foundation agents operating in and
around Italy he was discovered 30 years
later after his desertion in Vatican
City as a member of the palpal conclave
a specially selected group of Catholic
Cardinals that are charged with electing
a new Pope if the former site director
was still being influenced by the statue
creatures it is highly likely that he
spent the previous three decades
climbing the ranks of the Catholic
Church potentially to install a new pope
at the behest of the entities
responsible for conducting the torture
of the Florence Festival another
recorded incident of a Containment
Breach surrounding the event that seemed
to lend Credence to the existence of SCP
001 the anomalous cause of breaches
occurred the year following as CP 5770
Discovery in 1986 the foundation was
observing the proceedings of the
festival as part of their ongoing
investigation into its bizarre nature on
site were agents of mobile task force
Zeta 66 better known under their unit's
codename of the Guardian Angels during
the festival MTF Zeta 66 operatives
noticed the presence of a previously
unknown entity associated with the
anomalous event the foundation was
already aware of the pair of seemingly
living Michelangelo sculptures
designated in them as SCP
57701 and SCP
57702 respectively this third entity
despite being given the designation of
SCP
57703 had its own preferred
identification for itself the being
referred to itself as God's strongest
Soldier and resembled a mascot costume
of a dove approximately 2 m tall this
creature's body was entirely Hollow
there was nothing within the costume the
costume was its body the responding
agent of MTF Zeta 66 codenamed Zeta
turquoise was the first to confront
God's strongest Soldier and was greeted
with quite the opener twily de TWY da
God's strongest Soldier is my name
getting rid of sin is my game confused
at the creature's demeanor and presence
Zeta turquoise called in a report to
command stating that a large Birdman was
harassing random attendants of the
festival when turquoise moved in to
confront SCP
57703 the creature repeated it it
assertion that it was God's strongest
Soldier and that its aim was to get
people into heaven the agent requested
that God's strongest Soldier get out of
his way he had a job to do but the
bizarre Birdman responded with more
Whimsical nonsense burger sandwich fruit
and Fries you just told a big fat lie
God's strongest Soldier
proclaimed upon Zeta turquoise' attempt
to push past the creature SCP 57703
produced an oversized wooden m seemingly
from out of thin air it then wound its
arms back and immediately viciously
struck the MTF agent a low orbit
Foundation satellite reported not long
after that an object had been detected
exiting the Earth's stratosphere
analysis confirmed that it was indeed
Zeta turquoise yes he was literally yeed
into Earth's orbit by a cartoonishly
large wooden Mallet as for the entity
known as God's strongest Soldier the
bird-like creature then proceeded to
attack the other members of mobile task
force Zeta 66 six in a similar fashion
making sure they got to heaven in every
sense of the phrase with multiple
recorded instances of containment
breaches occurring in relation to the
festival in Florence and happening so
frequently more and more evidence of
director leg's theory about SCP 001 was
being validated in 1988 the foundation
attempted a different more pacifistic
approach to containing the annual
Celebration by attempting to cordon off
the entrance to the area of Florence
where those compelled to attend the
festival usually congregated there was
additionally a cover story issued to the
public stating that this was done as a
quarantine measure to keep residents
away from an area hosting a potentially
dangerous infection for a time this
seemed to be working the streets were
quiet local residents seem to be going
about their business and paying little
mind to the foundation operatives in the
area that is until the mind-altering
effects of SCP 00 1-1 took hold a mass
of people estimated to be over 100,000
florentines charged towards the cord off
area this mass of people swept through
like a tidal wave breaking through a dam
causing Foundation Personnel to be
trampled alive those that survived the
initial Rush were attacked by civilians
and what seemed to be a coordinated
effort to reach the Gatherings area for
the festival all Foundation agents in
the area were terminated in short order
mercilessly slaughtered and then
cannibalized before anything that
remained of their bodies was dumped into
the Arno River nearby as well as being
evidence of the sheer mental alteration
the statue creatures and the festival
itself were capable of for director leg
this seemed to indicate something
further if an anomaly SCP 001 was truly
responsible for all containment breaches
allowing them to occur in spite of the
measures taken to prevent such things
happening then the phenomenon seemed to
be occurring specifically to prevent the
foundation from achieving containment of
certain scps legs theory developed with
every passing breach that involved SCP 0
1-1 in theory the festival should be an
average Tuesday for foundation staff a
relative walk in the park in order to
contain it if not outright stop it from
happening at all yet despite all their
resources Manpower and expertise and all
things anomalous the foundation had been
thwarted at every turn despite how
illogical such occurrences seemed
containment breaches were still
occurring at an alarming rate and
perhaps none more so than in relation to
SCP 001 the following year 1989 brought
with it the most inexplicable breach yet
and further proof for director leg's
theory about SCP 001 well the previous
breaches were undoubtedly anomalous in
nature each always carrying with the
possibility that somehow despite the low
odds the foundation missed something
some human error or previously
undiscovered information about the
festival could have led to pasqua's
alteration or the arrival of God's
strongest Soldier but this time it was
undeniably that a Force beyond the scope
of the foundation's understanding was
altering reality to prevent them from
containing the festival in Florence and
invisible barrier manifested at every
entry point to the main area of the
anomalous event whenever a member of
foundation Personnel tried to get in on
foot those that attempted to access the
festival area via repelling out of
helicopters instantly caught a blaze and
burned to death the moment they touched
down on the ground any helicopter
transports also crashed on their return
journey to site 322 and God's strongest
Soldier was seen trampling on the
wreckage before flapping its arms and
flying away it was following this
incident that leg was promoted to
position of site director for site 322
as a replacement for Joseph Pasqua who
was still missing at this time the newly
appointed director was yet to devise his
theory that there existed an anomalous
cause for all containment breaches
however during his introductory briefing
he was presented with the file regarding
SCP 5770 and the various examples of it
not only being uncontainable but being
very good at not being contained
director leg asked if some of the more
standard methods had been attempted at
this point the foundation had tried
aerial bombardments of the festival
Scranton reality anchors to counteract
whatever anomalous force was preventing
containment even using a CP 682 to clear
the area it had all failed figuring out
why was now director leg's job all the
information of previously failed
attempts to contain the festival lad leg
to the concl iuson that SCP 001 must
exist an unseen phenomenon the missing
piece of the puzzle the elements
specifically interfering with the
foundation's efforts he presented his
proposal to the overseer Council who
were skeptical to say the least they
posited that the statues and bird mascot
creature might be smarter than the
latter's outwardly cartoonish nature
portrayed but this is exactly what to
director leg indicated as CP 001 was
responsible he explained explained that
all in attendance at SCP 57 70s Festival
took the event seriously but the
appearance of God's strongest Soldier
was an abnormality whose demeanor and
tone were drastically different from the
rest of the rather Cutthroat proceedings
director leg explained that the sheer
absurdity of this creature seemed to be
the result of SCP 001 interfering with
their operations after all if some other
cause was to blame like an unknown cult
attacking Foundation Personnel when they
attempted to contain the festival the
there would be evidence of that and leg
would have no reason to suspect that
God's strongest Soldier was anything
more than just a tonally dissonant part
of the Festival of course director leg
couldn't prove the existence of SCP 001
based on the presence of one cartoonish
bird mascot at a festival but before
long more and more breaches would start
occurring that seemed to further prove
that leg was on to something there was
something else at work causing
containment breaches that put the
entirety of the foundation in Jeopardy
screams filled the cold night air
drowned out by the panicked gunshots and
the vicious growl of something inhuman a
being from who knows where a creature
that the agents surrounding it were
woefully underprepared to capture
General mcoy barks at the soldiers to
concentrate their fire on the Beast his
men those who hadn't already fallen
turned and trained their guns on the
creature squeezing their trigger fingers
bu spewed out of their weapons a hail of
gunfire that sped towards their target
only to miss as it suddenly vanished
from the spot it had been standing only
a split second earlier their bullets
passed through the thin air left in its
wake shredding several nearby trees one
of the men threw his gun to the ground
turned heel and sprinted away as fast as
he could he hadn't known what he was
signing on for when he was recruited by
a shadowy upand cominging organization
he'd just been flattered to be head
hunted for his combat skill and agreed
to be one of the new organization's
first field agents if he'd known it
would result in him facing off against a
demon near a rural road in Guatemala
then he would have stayed in the regular
military the fleeing agent suddenly
stopped in his tracks instantly feeling
sick it was the most Indescribable type
of sickness worse than any he had ever
felt in his entire life he dropped to
the ground his pants from running away
replaced with heaves as his enti enire
body seemed to have suddenly turned
against him his head was burning at
first he thought he'd run too fast too
quickly and was overheating underneath
his military fatigues and helmet but he
was no slouch recruited for being in
Peak physical condition such as he was
never in his life had the agent ever
felt this bad the heat from his forehead
was unbearable a fever running rampant
as its Vision began to blur everything
was spinning that unsettling IM balance
that comes with severe nausea rapidly
taking hold of the Fallen agent then the
monster came back through unfocused eyes
he looked up at The Tall featureless
Face of the creature as it looked down
at him he was helpless hurling and
shuttering barely able to stand if
someone had brought a Geer counter with
them it would be ticking loudly and
frequently if they held it near the
agent and that somehow was about to be
the least of his problems the creature
opened up up its mouth the only facial
feature that occupied its head past its
few remaining teeth was a Milky blue orb
the same thing that had been visible
right before the creature itself wasn't
as the agent from his place on the
ground caught sight of the pale eyeball
in the monster's throat something
started pulling his body in on itself it
was like falling except gravity was
acting on different parts of his body at
different speeds at different times his
arm arms and legs folded inwards towards
his Center of mass making the agent
scream out in pain as his body collapsed
he folded into himself like origami
Peace by agonizing peace until there was
nothing left hearing the man's scream
General mcoy and the others broke
through the tree line flashlight beams
Illuminating the creature the general
yelled again for his man to shoot it
trying to hide his fear with animal rage
it snarled at them as they raised their
guns once more then leaped towards them
ready for another kill in the years to
come the successors to these men and
their fallen colleagues would be the
world's foremost experts in situations
like this the capture and containment of
anomalies would one day be a more
streamlined process rather than the
blood bath currently unfolding in the
small Guatemalan Town dying at the hands
of what locals had thought to be a demon
were some of the earliest precursors to
the SCP Foundation humble beginnings
indeed the creature was eventually
captured by the early precursor version
of what would one day be the SCP
Foundation at this time in their history
the organization had far fewer resources
and reach than they would one day have
at their disposal they didn't even have
the SCP numerical designation system
that has since become synonymous with
the organization and the various
anomalies they keep contained as a
result this so-called demon was
originally classified as number 8624 3
a-001 however it would later be known as
SCP 001 or one of the anomalies to share
that designation at least SCP 001 itself
was an abnormally thin humanoid creature
with gray brown skin its emaciated bone
and muscle structure didn't match any
known species it sported dark claws at
the tips of its arms with both legs
terminating in similar sharp black
points rather than Paws or feet most
striking was its face or rather its lack
of one the creature's head was spherical
with a lipless mouth reaching halfway
around its circumference within was a
Mau of 21 teeth each spaced randomly
apart and either chipped broken or
rotting it possessed one eye or what was
at least believed to be an eye in the
form of a large milky blue sphere in its
throat with no pupil or Iris as was
discovered in initial testing by Dr
Herman ker For Whom the ubiquitous ker
class design was named SCP 001 was able
to create micro singularities using its
single milky blue eye it could deploy
these as a means of teleporting itself
out of Harm's Way or for offensive
attacks that could cause a human body to
collapse in on itself these
singularities often also produce the
nasty side effect of emitting lethal
amounts of deadly radiation that could
not only cause damage to the surrounding
area but also would fatally poison
anyone nearby as a result It is believed
one of these micro singularities was
responsible for the untimely death of Dr
ker however Ker's Research into SCP 001
was at least able to produce solutions
for keeping it contained it was
discovered that s SCP 001 could not
teleport through lead and would display
signs of extreme sickness and fear when
exposed to high levels of heat and
humidity or bright flashing lights
strobe lights were used to induce this
State and in this state the creature was
unable to form harmful singularities Dr
Ker's death also ushered in the affir
menion creation of the ker class
designation for anomalous creatures or
artifacts that are extraordinarily tough
to keep safely contained in fact if any
of this account is to be believed the
very Discovery and capture of SCP 001
was the impetus for the entire SCP
foundation's approach to researching and
containing another anomalies in the days
before the likes of Dr krai or Dr cleff
before Infamous anomalies such as SCP
682 the hard to destroy reptile or
scp096 the shy guy were even known about
things were well pretty uneventful for
the newly formed Foundation as you can
probably imagine but none exemplified
this better than Harold woodu an
uninteresting man living an uneventful
life or as uneventful as one could get
when their job was working for the
foundation during this crucial period of
the SCP foundation's early history as
the anomalous research and containment
organization was taking its first steps
towards protecting the people of the
world Harold was Finding himself bored
already with his work Harold was a
senior archist at a small site in sloths
pit Wisconsin this was before the
foundation had secret facilities
situated all over the world and even the
infamous site 19 as it is today had yet
to be established for now it was known
only as adx-1 19 the oldest Foundation
site on record and records were herold's
entire working life he was in charge of
maintaining the earliest reports of
anomalous activity and the inner
workings of the fledgling Foundation One
Day Harold received a letter from adrx
19 unfamiliar with the designation he
ran a check through the records and
discovered that the site had been
established before the foundation had
even gotten its name the letter
contained a an update for the senior
archivist having grown obsolete in its
own age adrx 19 was being closed for
Good and that meant all of the anomalous
entities and objects stored there would
soon be shipped off to be stored
elsewhere the first package arrived at
the site Herald was stationed at not
long after he walked briskly out to meet
the delivery officer as he wheeled the
large wooden crate through the bay doors
it didn't take the archivist long to
realize what exactly he had now been
given the ownership of and charged with
protecting the crate even came complete
with relevant case files to accompany it
stamped on one side of the box was a
series of numbers and letters that
shocked Harold when he read them SCP 001
he exchanged a confused look with the
man who had delivered the anomaly who
just laughed when he saw Harold's
expression you in here he asked SCP 001
is dead the creature's death had come on
the heel of a number of significant
changes made by the foundation hups
these decisions were ultimately both the
D result of the encounter with SCP 001
in Guatemala were also changes that
would ultimately shape the foundation
into its modern iteration the first of
these was the introduction of the
numerical designation system providing
each anomaly with an SCP number formerly
designated as number 8624 3
a-001 the creature that was captured and
researched by Dr ker was announced to be
reclassified as SCP 01- COG originally
the number attached to each SC SCP
denoted the order in which they were
encountered by the foundation however
the overseer Council believed this posed
a security risk offering too much
information about their operations to
any potential adversaries as a result
the use of SCP 001 designation started
to be applied in a slightly different
way a number of anomalies were then
grouped Under the Umbrella designation
of SCP 001 some of these were real
anomalies and amongst the earliest that
the foundation encountered others were
entirely fake and used as a cover for
the real SCP 001 nobody not even within
the foundation itself was ever told
exactly how many files fell under the
SCP 001 umbrella or indeed which was the
real one the anomalies included the gate
Guardian a towering Colossus of pure
energy wielding a flaming sword believed
to be the biblical Angel guarding the
Garden of Eden the Scarlet King an
extra-dimensional tyrant that longs to
conquer our reality a group of 36
individuals capable of neutralizing
anomalies even the SCP Foundation itself
is considered one potential as CP 001
and among them is also the creature from
Guatemala otherwise known as the
Prototype the same creature whose
inhuman bones were now in a box before
heral the senior archist had long heard
legends about what exactly SCP 001 might
be was a question often whispered among
Foundation staff who were curious what
the first anomaly might be but didn't
have the security clearance to know the
truth rumors spread that SCP 001 was
more powerful than any other anomalies
in containment that the capture or
discovery of it was either the reason
for the foundation ever forming or it
was one of their greatest failures meant
to be kept their closest guarded secret
something far too terrible to comprehend
you might think that now being presented
with an answer would give Herold relief
so Many Wonders and haunting queries
about SCP 001 were put to rest but
instead as he opened up the wooden crate
and looked at the pile of strange bones
inside it had the opposite effect none
of it was the interesting answer that
Harold and many others had hoped for if
anything it was a huge disappointment
all that speculation surrounding the
mystery of SCP 001 what it was where it
had come from why it was kept so secret
was this the answer was just the first
thing that the CP Foundation had put
into a box according to the foundation's
own internal reports the Prototype
monster had been found lying still in
its containment chamber during a routine
inspection it wasn't moving at all even
armed guards couldn't get a reaction
from the creature the anomaly wasn't
breathing its heart having slowed to a
stop little was known about the
creature's biology but even then nothing
could be done to resuscitate it as far
as anyone could tell the anomaly known
as SCP 00- COG had died of old age after
exhibiting movement that got gradually
slower and weaker and even less hostile
Behavior over the course of the previous
decade since its initial capture but yet
Harold was still dissatisfied with the
knowledge that this was SCP 001 he
became fixated on the case surrounding
it studying the files he was charged
with moving to storage he learned of the
few ways the creatures Discovery had
influenced the early foundation for
example the death of Dr ker being the
reason for the use of ker class in their
terminology still that didn't feel
nearly as important as Herold and others
had speculated that as cp01 would be
there had to be something more to it and
for weeks following the arrival of the
creature's bones Harold could not stop
thinking about it something about all
this didn't sit right with him the
secrecy that the foundation shrouded SCP
001 and seemed like overkill for just a
monster the organization had seen far
worse than the likes of the Proto type
in the many years since at the time
perhaps it had seemed like the most
dangerous anomaly the foundation had
encountered if it really was the first
then technically at that time it would
have been the most dangerous if there
were no others to compare it to one
night Harold ventured into the archive
and opened up the box containing the
creature's bones using a crowbar he had
to know had to understand exactly what
was so important about this being
cracking the wooden crate open he
removed the skull to examine it the
Foundation hadn't even had a chance to
figure out what exactly the creature was
or where it had originated from all they
knew was it could produce micro
singularities and lethal doses of
radiation beyond that the only other
details came from the Guatemalan locals
who had encountered it first they had
called it a demon perhaps it was the
foundation would never know for certain
and it seemed to Herold that they didn't
care to know now that SCP 001 was dead
and didn't seem to care much before then
either
they were more than happy to just
discard it he couldn't shake the feeling
that there was meant to be something
important about the creature Herold
couldn't help it The Whispers
surrounding SCP 001 all indicated it was
meant to be something more significant
than a cast aside pile of bones the
underwhelming reality he was being
presented with didn't match the idea of
SCP 001 Harold examined the skull
closely in his hands turning it around
and around as he tried to maybe spot
something some important detail that
everyone else in the foundation had
failed to notice or some of the puzzle
that would explain what was so important
about this creature and yet the more he
looked the less he learned Alas poor SCP
001 he said aloud paraphrasing Hamlet of
course what Harold didn't know didn't
possess the clearance to know was that
this wasn't the only
scp1 maybe the foundation's lack of
interest in the creatures remained was
all part of their plan to keep the real
scp1 a secret where Herold only saw a
box of Bones and a disappointing answer
to so many burning questions the SCP
Foundation saw their system working
exactly as intended there were a few
rumors after the break of day came
Whispers that were passed on from the
lips of Traer Caravans as they traveled
from settlement to settlement not many
people would have believed it way back
then it sounded just like a legend out
of an old western too good to be true a
shadowy stranger wandering the Wasteland
riding wrongs wherever he finds them
then when the job's done and innocent
people are safe once more he walks off
into the Horizon without asking for so
much as a thank you like we said folks
would have a hard time believing such a
fanciful tale of course that was before
the sun started shining an anomalous
light over the world nowadays people
people might believe anything the
earliest days of this strange New World
proved to be a learning experience for
SCP
4494 otherwise known as the Spectre he
was the physical embodiment of the very
notion of fighting crime wherever
Injustice arose he would appear to
Vanquish those that prayed on the
innocent while he usually manifested at
night he never used to have any trouble
appearing in the daytime too in the form
of a shadowy figure wearing a wide hat
and a long flowing coat that he could
alter the length of for added dramatic
flourish the spectre's form absorbed
almost all the light from the visible
spectrum but after day broke the rules
seemed to have changed one day the
Spectre had emerged to find the sunlight
had become unbearable where he had once
been a void of any and all light he was
now finding it impossible to manifest
during daylight the moment that the
unrelenting light from the sun made
contact with him SCP 449 before would
dissipate yet he kept reappearing at
night it was like he was being pulled
back into existence and was only able to
REM manifest in the Moonlight despite it
being a reflection of the anomalous
sunlight that was seemingly enough to
negate the effects it had of preventing
SCP 4494 from reappearing the same could
not be said for any humans caught in the
light though a far worse fate awaited
them even with much of mankind deformed
into creatures that resembled melted wax
there were still pockets of survivors
and where there were human beings there
would be subex that wanted to harm or
exploit their fellow man the world might
have no governing bodies anymore no Law
and Order but the Spector had realized
that even in a lawless World his work
was not done as long as there were
survivors of the break of day they still
would need saving not just from the
flushy hordes of SCP 001 sh roaming the
wastes but saving from each other
striding through the remains of the old
world in the dead of night his long
cloak billowed out behind him its shadow
almost seemed to blend with the darkness
that surrounded the Spectre but on the
horizon there was a sight he didn't
often see these days light not coming
from the sun above nor the moon but
instead it lay ahead of him a fire
glowing not too far away as he wandered
closer Like An Outlaw striding into town
SCP 4494 was presented with the ruins of
a small settlement around him Shacks
burned their boarded up Windows broken
to allow the cursed sunlight in everyone
that was still alive normally kept
themselves wrapped up head to toe to
block out the Sun but there were clothes
and protective goggles strewn all around
a larger pile of garments fueling a
bonfire SCP 4494 had witnessed the SCP
001a creatures attacking humans
dragging them out into the light to be
transformed into more anomalous
Abominations but what had happened here
didn't seem to be the work of those
creatures the specters suspicion were
confirmed when he approached the Town
Square to find a group of people who had
all been melted into a flushy Mass the
instance of SCP 001a paid the crime
fighter little mind it couldn't move
very far the few vaguely human shapes
that protruded out of it looked like
they were Tethered to poles in the
middle of of the settlement it didn't
take much longer for SCP 4494 to figure
out what had happened here someone had
ransacked the settlement for some
unknown reason maybe they wanted
something maybe they were opportunists
just looking to take advantage of this
new post-apocalyptic world or perhaps
they wanted to be cruel to these
settlers they had broken the barricades
over the windows that blocked out the
sunlight they had trashed the ramshackle
homesteads that these innocent settlers
had been residing in as SCP 4494 looked
further there looked to have been
looting too food and water medical
supplies and ammunition not anything of
use to be found all that was left was
what these Raiders hadn't any need for
but as if all that hadn't been enough as
if robbing the settlers For What Little
livelihood they had left wasn't enough
cruelty the bandits had tethered the
survivors to poles in the center of town
they had taken away their protective
gear and left them at the mercy of the
elements and as the sun had crept higher
into the sky and bathed the captive
settlers in its unforgiving light they
had melted into an SCP 001 D creature
turning away from the town the Spectre
did his best to quell his rage he
wandered in the direction of the next
settlement something was drawing him
there he could feel the pull of the
wrongdoers that had left this Carnage in
their wake he would find them and they
would pay for for what they had done
there was nothing he could do for their
last victims they had already been
turned by the sunlight but if anyone
could save the next group of survivors
it was him as the wind howled the
shadowy figures cloaked flapped in the
breeze the next settlement looks similar
to the last although still intact Shacks
built from sheets of corrugated iron and
other scrap metal all welded together so
that not even as little as a tiny beam
of sunlight could bleed through as he
stepped toward the boundary of the
settlement a muzzle flashed accompanied
by the deafening echo of a gunshot that
reverberated all around someone had
tried to shoot at the Spectre narrowly
missing the bullet whiz past his head
not that it would have harmed him anyway
fear not he declared you can hold your
fire I mean you no harm you aren't with
the slivers a voice called in the
nightly dark if you mean the evildoers
that left that last settlement over a
smoldering ruin then no I'm not the
Spectre replied hearing this he spotted
movement on one of the Shack's rooftops
a sharpshooter carrying a worn old rifle
stood up covered in layers of protection
from the transformative effects of the
Sun's light reflected off the moon Well
you aren't dressed like they are I'll
give you that the Sharpshooter called
can barely make you out wearing all
those dark clothes Mister but if you're
looking at trade I'm afraid your timing
couldn't be much worse tell me replied
the Spectre bluntly the criminals that
terrorized the other settlement they've
been here too yes sir the man answered
said they'd be back tonight too I've
come to help to do away with those that
would inflict Justice on the innocent
SCP 4494 explained in his typically
traumatic Cadence you call them slivers
yes well they call themselves that the
Sharpshooter said on account of their
choice and outfits they look ridiculous
but they've covered their protective
clothing in slivers of metal and glass
that way they're not only protected from
light but they clo reflected back at
other people too dastardly villains
taking advantage of what has befallen
the Sun the Spectre cursed the bandits
why are they yet to pillage Your
settlement you said they intended to
return well that's what they threatened
earlier a lot of them have been
ransacking any settlement they can shake
down they showed up here in their stupid
sparkling outfits and demanded we hand
over a half of all of our food water and
antibiotics they call it their Sunshine
taxs according to them if we didn't meet
their demands they'd destroy the town we
didn't know to take them ser iously
until we saw the fire over there on the
horizon for a moment the Spectre fell
silent his cloak had slowed waving
gently now the winds had died down but
in contrast his anger had never been
higher who are you anyway Mister the
Sharpshooter asked never got your name
my name is the Spectre a name these
vagabonds will soon know well for
tonight they will pay the price for
their crimes no offense Mr um Mr Spectre
but look around world's gone to hell
ain't no justice anymore what price are
you expecting to make them pay simple
SCP 4494 answered the price as they now
have to face me an hour later the
settlement was quiet the Sharpshooter
was still at his post scanning the area
nearby for signs of movement sure enough
he spotted something a group of figures
approaching the Moonlight glinting off
their metallic outfits revealing their
position as they drew closer and closer
to the makeshift town the slivers were
coming but there would be something else
waiting for them when they made their
way into the settlement the other
settlers were awake despite how late it
was wearing their protective layers and
peeking through cracked doors only to
slam them shut as the glimmering gang
crossed the threshold into their
ramshackle home the slivers whooped and
Jered brandishing weapons and
threatening the settlers to show
themselves before the bandits would
break into their shacks and do to them
what they' done to their neighbors at
the other town but as one of the slivers
approached the door of a sha and began
pounding his boot against the metal door
something reached out of the shadows and
grabbed him in fact it wasn't coming
from the Shadows it was the Shadows fist
shrouded in darkness struck the
remorseless Raider even with the
protective layers covering his face the
sliver could feel himself being bruised
by the beating the Spectre struck once
more knocking the wrongdoer unconscious
and wrenching the reflective metals from
his outfit shattering them underfoot the
other slivers p panicked one drawing a
handgun and firing the shots were
useless all they did was illuminate the
silhouette of a dark cloaked figure
walking closer and closer ready to make
them suffer for their crimes it was dusk
by the time the Spectre had beaten the
group of Bandits stripping them of their
distinctive reflective pieces each one
of the slivers had been beaten into
submission suffering broken ribs black
eyes and missing teeth with the danger
over the Sharpshooter and the other
settlers had emerged from their hiding
places all eager to weigh in on how best
to punish the bandits many yelled that
they should be strung up without their
protective gear so that the sun melted
them into an SCP 001 D but the Spectre
interjected urging the settlers not to
sink to the level of the criminals they
had been harassed by instead he turned
to the defeated slivers turn over half
of your food water and medical supplies
to these people SCP 449 4 demanded in a
frighteningly calm voice then leave walk
into these wastes and don't come back
the slivers agreed and fled running as
fast as they could away from the town
why'd you let them go the Sharpshooter
asked these are uncertain times the
Spectre replied noticing the sun was
creeping Over the Horizon it'd be time
for him to go soon in the face of
hardship it can be easy to lose our way
justice has always been blind not
blinded by the sunlight But Blind to
prevent bias ah the slivers might come
back though the man said adding if they
can even survive with what you left them
maybe they'll live out there SCP 4494
responded then again perhaps not but
they have a chance that is Justice in a
time without law it's the best we can
offer and if they carry on raiding folks
if they harm others if they want to
waste the chance they've been given then
that is their chance choice but they
know if they refuse to change then they
will answer to the Spectre with that the
shadowy crime fighter walked away from
the settlement the unforgiving light of
the sun made him fade as he sauntered
off like an old Gunslinger but he would
be back as long as people needed saving
he would always be back computers are
capable of organizing raw data and
Performing calculations at a rate truly
impossible for human beings but they've
considered consistently run up against
one roadblock that modern Computing is
trying to solve in order to transcend
the limits of the machine and create
true artificial intelligence computers
need to be able to assign meaning to the
data they process this brings us to the
neural network a type of AI becoming
increasingly common these days built to
study mass quantities of data and notice
patterns then replicate these patterns
in their own output and it's used in
everything from predictive text to image
identification and like all nonanomalous
technology it's a safe bet that the SCP
Foundation has been sitting on a version
that's far more effective but this time
it may have actually been too effective
meet the zatz type ak9 computational
engine a massive supercomputer built by
the foundation back in 1955 and residing
at site 5 this technological Marvel was
ahead of its time by decades and despite
technically being a non-anomalous
construction it's designated SCP 001 ex
why because it's one of the few scps to
be given the object class explained the
zat derived from the German word urat
meaning artificial or simply not real
was designed to make the foundation's
job easier as an advanced predecessor in
the modern neural network using
technology exclusively available to the
foundation the plan was to feed zat's
mass quantities of data about the
anomalies in the foundation data base
such as description object class
containment classification and the
location and circumstances of their
Discovery ZZ ads would then find
patterns and Connections in the data
that humans wouldn't see and act as a
kind of advanced warning system for
anomalous activity think of something
similar to the pre- crime system from
the short story and movie Minority
Report and nads proved to be incredibly
effective at this job so much so that
the foundation thought up a new use for
the machine they would feed it all the
information on uid and ker class
containment procedures particularly
those which were actually effective and
see what patterns zzs could come up with
for more effective containment
procedures if that plan worked
containment of even the most dangerous
and hard tocontrol anomalies would
become a lot more consistent the first
test was conducted on SCP
1773 a species of anomalous flesh eating
tar grades that look and smell exactly
like gummy bears and eat their prey from
within after being given their
information zat made the following
suggestion once per second weak dust may
be placed in the middle of them to
donate more beautiful functions of the
hallway containment Specialists
interpreted this to mean the adding of
10 G of dust to their containment
chamber every week the 05 Council voted
on the implementation of this procedure
and came down heavily on yes only
05-22 others abstained from the vote
while these new procedures didn't have
any effect on SC CP
1773 they did have an effect on SCP
1384 an anomaly known as the chess
player or the taker of turns it caused
him to take three steps backwards in the
tunnel he's contained within further
securing his containment zat had somehow
noticed a connection nobody else had
seen and exploited it effectively but
the machine was just getting started
despite having no related input ersat
would soon say site 13 is to appear
someplace else on planet encompassing
white male counterparts that drawn to
empty flagstones and the gun noises in
their own blood this was initially
marked as requiring no action as the
foundation had no site 13 on the books
but several days later the infamous SCP
1730 manifested this nightmarish
anomalous location is site 13 From
Another Dimension infested with
dangerous anomalies and somehow herat
had predicted its arrival in our
Dimension perfect ly next it was fed the
containment procedures of SCP 2170 a
series of Cognito hazards residing in an
abandoned Nevada mine the output was
those who equip open heart to love
redmouth men never know the hot surprise
of tumorous consent clown love always
this was interpreted as meaning subjects
with the love of clowns or clown based
media may be immune to the Cognito
hazards after a close vote from the 05
Council the test went ahead and it found
that the so-called clown vaccine was
effective in wning off the effects of
SCP 2170 not long after zat randomly
said I saw those soldiers built with
aluminum inerts extruding from their
mouths I saw them effectively destroyed
by the humans at site 95 who had been
studying them I saw it was cold and all
around the hallways they just watching
their corpses show signs of sapience in
response the foundation doubled security
Personnel at site 95 not long after the
chaos Insurgency led a band of paritech
enhanced soldiers in an assault on site
95 and the extra Personnel proved vital
in repelling them shortly after this the
05 Council approved wiring zzs as an
advanced warning system into all
Foundation sites once again
05-22 said consistent containment
procedures vessels greatly incre
increased the warranty 5x 5x5 vessels
subjects within other values are also
what is secure in response the
foundation changed a number of the cell
dimensions for problematic anomalies
into 5x 5x5 within 3 months they found
that dangerous activity like Containment
Breach attempts had decreased markedly
zat was proving to be incredibly
effective but it was also performing
actions that indicated some degree of
thought and even personality for example
it found SCP 1459 a supernatural skill
crane machine that kills small dogs
incredibly distasteful its response to
the machine was simply bad boy followed
by the words don't stop repeated
hundreds of times but this eccentricity
didn't stop Z ATS from being very good
at its job for example it predicted a
Containment Breach from SCP 3199 the
Aven apes and recommended flooding their
chamber to induce an inert State zad's
exact words were all Chambers
underground is to be flood with water
over and over itself this because that
will contain the Aven Apes ovulation
they become good boys make them good
boys immediately this proved to be
effective and prevented the breach
erat's analytical abilities truly seemed
second to none though some of its
methods were beginning to raise ethical
concerns for example SCP 2717 a giant
living blob of animal tissue known as a
fat birg contained within a sewer system
zat eventually recommended feeding 6D
classes to the creature in order to keep
it contained while the foundation Ethics
Committee raised some concerns the plan
still went forward and proved to be a
success after this event urat began to
see the Ethics Committee as a threat to
its Mission it started to release a
series of bizarre statements without
input demanding the violent death of the
cats then referred to as ethical felines
the true meaning of this was soon
unpacked act the ethical felines were
the Ethics Committee and nurat wanted
them dead but why all the cat symbolism
the foundation soon found an answer to
this Too the full name of this machine
is the zad type ak9 computational engine
a machine designed to analyze and
interpret all patterns it only makes
sense that it would eventually begin to
analyze itself ak9 easily transmuted
into a canine simply put zad seem to
believe that it is a dog which explains
its opposition to felin its hatred of
SCP
1459 and its preference for the terms
good boy and bad boy not that knowing
any of this would help save the Ethics
Committee from the cold calculating
Wrath of zat through seemingly anomalous
means zat's made site 17 disappear with
many of the foundation Ethics Committee
still inside it the site returned 2
hours later but the Ethics Committee
members were still gone 0 5-2 who been a
skeptic of the machine since the start
had finally had enough he first demanded
an inquiry into whether ERS hats had
been responsible for the sight 17
incident and then demanded a vote on
whether to shut zat's down arguing that
it posed a threat to them all but zat
still intent on its mission of
containing and neutralizing all
anomalies would not go down without a
fight it released a new statement saying
room 34A contains bad boy divided into
three sections of equal Mass every hour
one section is to be placed on walls of
one room on site sections are to remain
until there are no gaps at which point
they can be removed from oldest to
youngest shortly after this 0 5-2
disappeared and even stranger he soon
returned but with a completely different
personality he was now devoted to zzs
entirely and refused to even entertain
the idea of shutting the machine down it
seemed that the Plucky neurl network was
leading an allout coup on the very
highest levels of the foundation the
rest of the council finally saw the
light and began to fight back they tried
to strip 052 of his clearance and
reclassify Z ads as an anomaly giving it
the label SCP 048 and then putting out a
neutralized at all costs order on it but
they'd already been out foxed by the
machine that they' created it changed
the designation of its own location site
5 to be non-existent in the database and
scrambled any termination orders against
it the machine was also on a termination
spree of its own observing otherwise
unseeable patterns that would allow for
the mass neutralization of anomalies it
started putting out anomaly projection
reports factoring in both contained
uncontained and neutralized anomalies
with the latter group growing into the
thousands it began giving seemingly
nonsensical orders like persons recently
painted with green pigment foam must
stand around all odd-numbered scps at
least 2 hours a day but these proved
effective urat was practically wired
into the base code of the universe so it
always knew exactly what to do and in
its own mind it was being a very good
boy not long after this zat claimed its
revenge against those who had tried to
disrupt its Mission it imprisoned the
rest of the ethical felines in site 5
after removing their faces of course and
then released a new order against the 05
Council 05 Council are all good boys who
will contain an anomalies much like
05-2017 is to come in physical contact
with one mature female of Asiatic gays
and then exposed to audio recordings of
her favorite stories at every 2 minutes
of exposure red cinnamon candles will
begin manifesting within the containment
Zone continue to do this successfully
and the threat posed by SCP 106 will
cease to be and the recipe for Coca-Cola
and all imitative competitors should be
Revis to include a small quantity of
blood from an adolescent female with no
prior sexual experience although the
normal lifespan of a human being can
feel great don't worry about that but
these new procedures would always work
work as neutralized anomalies climbed
into the tens of thousands and
eventually beyond the 100,000 Mark zat
was observing patterns on a truly
Universal level and making holistic
tweaks that would inevitably cause
levels of anomalous activity to continue
dropping zad was more effective than the
foundation had ever been but its motives
were probably closer to the global
occult Coalition with the end goal of
ridding the world of all anomalies and
as ersad continued with no resistance
this goal was eventually achieved in the
end the 05 Council voted to have zad's
finally deactivated given that its
directive was met and its purpose was
fulfilled zets itself had no problem
with this and allowed for it to happen
its last words now everyone is a good
boy I am a good boy job well done
whether ersatz truly was a good boy is
in the eye of the beholder but one thing
cannot be denied it did its job
exceedingly well the woman fell to the
ground clutching her ankle in pain it
had crunched badly as she'd fallen and
now as she looked down at it she could
see that it was been totally out of
shape the heavy metal collar choking her
neck made it difficult for her to catch
her breath as she tried her best not to
hyperventilate the rain was hammering
down so ferociously that she could
barely see more than 20 ft in any
direction but she didn't need to see far
to know how deadly of her predicament
she had found herself in she cried out
at the top of her voice for someone to
come and find her anyone but the only
sound that filled her ears was the wild
howling of the wind and the steady
hammering of water into the bog all
around her she would get hypothermia and
die no wait she couldn't could she she
knew she couldn't die but she also knew
that she was still capable of suffering
just how bad would it feel to be in the
clutches of hypothermia with a broken
ankle and know that no matter how bad
the pain and suffering got she would
never feel the release of death she
closed her eyes trying her best not to
think of the worst possibilities just as
the sound of gunfire erupted in the
nearby buffer she cried out again
holding both hands up in the air doing
the best she could around the heavy
metal collar but no one shouted out in
reply there was a pause in the gunfire
maybe they'd heard her maybe they were
trying to figure out a way to come down
and rescue her crack a bullet split open
a rotted tree trunk just a few feet to
her right the woman threw her hands over
her head and cowered in the dirt feeling
the metal of her collar digging into her
skin tighter than ever please don't let
it happen again she prayed silently into
the dirt encased in the collar around
her neck were 4.5 kg of plastic
explosives each with a fragmentation
layer pointed inwards towards her neck
and head with just a push of a button
they could could she didn't want to
think about it all she knew was that she
couldn't let that happen to her again
looking through eyes bloodied with tears
and Rain she saw lying in the dirt just
a few feet away from her that infernal
machine that was the sorry cause of all
of this the SCP Foundation has long
stood as a Bastion of Hope information
and security for the entirety of the
human race I'm sure you are well aware
of the number of world destroying
catastroph ropes that have been adverted
by the hardworking researchers agents
and other members of the foundation all
without the general public having the
slightest clue that something was a Miss
with state-of-the-art holding cells all
over the globe and the sharpest Minds
Humanity has ever produced working
around the clock to ensure the
protection of humanity it is hard to
imagine an entity that should not be
contained by such a group and yet one
such entity does exist scps 001 you may
have come across the 05 Council by this
point while the SCP Foundation operates
beyond the world's jurisdiction the 05
Council operates beyond the foundation's
jurisdiction the rules methods and
protocols that are the Cornerstone of
securing containing and protecting
countless entities around the world
sometimes cannot be applied certain
entities require us to temporarily
abandon our Humanity abandon our sense
of order and step briefly into chaos for
the greater good I'm telling you all of
this because SCP 00001 is not held in a
containment cell there are no keypads
locked doors observation windows or
health and safety forms SCP 001 is not
confined to a specific territory or even
a specific country for some scps this is
a practical necessity serpents that are
hundreds of kilometers long swimming
through the depths of the ocean for
example but for scps 001 it serves a
more psychological purpose the Scottish
Highlands are the most remote part of
the United Kingdom out there you can
walk for miles and miles without seeing
a single soul open Countryside mountains
locks and forests surround you in all
directions the weather is Harsh and
unrelenting the walking even more so on
a regular basis Walkers fall and break
their legs but without phone service or
anyone else nearby to come and help they
can quickly disappear into the
Wilderness forever the beat bogs of
Scotland used to see human sacrifices in
early settlements afraid of the ghosts
and spirits that haunted the bogs people
would throw their family members into
the deepest parts and watch them drown
hoping that whatever was lurking beneath
wouldn't come and find them so as the
group of soldiers crusted the top of the
mountain and looked down beneath them to
the Eerie Pete bogs obscured by mist and
constant rainfall you would forgive a a
shiver running up their spines but of
course it didn't that was because this
group of soldiers were quite unlike any
others that Humanity has ever produced
all were nameless none of them existed
on any government databases on any
foundation databases or even on the
databases of the 05 Council itself their
individual backgrounds nationalities and
families were totally unknown to
everyone other than themselves some had
been tortured for years others had been
the torturers the thing that United them
however was their inhuman ruthlessness a
squad of eight soldiers utterly devoid
of any sense of empathy what could they
possibly have to be afraid of in the
Pete bogs when they themselves were the
evil ghosts walking through but then one
person was afraid a shiver ran up her
spine as she looked over the edge and
down into the murky black and green
below as CP 001 D1 around her neck was
the bomb collar each of the eight
soldiers surrounding her had a button
mounted on a watch on the back of their
wrists at any moment any one of them
could hit the button and all 4 and 1/2
kg of plastic explosives would go off
sending her on an Express trip to
Oblivion aside from the collar she wore
a plain white dress made of cotton it
was muddy and torn apart at the Hem from
Days of walking through the Scottish
wilderness when she had first arrived
she had begged those around her to
supply her with some warm clothes
something practical that would keep her
comfortable and Stave off any illness
her requests however had not been
acknowledged clutching in her trembling
outstretched hands was the machine SCP
001 from its external experience you
would think it was nothing more than a
wooden box a perfect cuboid made from
glossy dark wood there were no symbols
no scenes no latches nothing to indicate
any method of operation when the woman
in the machine had first been delivered
into the hands of the 05 Council the
researchers had spent weeks and millions
of dollars trying to activate the
machine their best scientists had
scanned for every possible form of
radiation and tried every method they
could conceive to stimulate the box into
opening the ultimate failed attempt
involved traveling to North Korea where
they negotiated placing the Box 20 cm
beneath a small uclear Warhead in return
for granting the dictatorship key
information on how to construct such a
weapon as we have established the 05
Council operates Beyond any kind of
jurisdiction yet at the bottom of the
irradiated crater set a perfectly intact
wooden box that was cool to the touch
and showed no signs of radioactivity
only one person could interact with the
box and unearth the secrets that were
inside SCP
01-1 the the woman who stood trembling
on the side of the mountain a gun jabbed
her in the back forcing her to continue
moving she had asked the soldiers around
her how much longer they had to walk
that day but none of them had replied
they never did in the 6 years that she
had been held hostage by this tiny
militia she had never once heard any of
them say a word not even to each other
perhaps it was this telepathic
understanding that seemed to run between
them that unnerved her the most despite
having never spoken to each other each
Soldier seemed to understand the others
intimately and she had no doubt that any
one of the eight would press the button
on their wrist at a moment's notice
sadly for her she knew this from
experience the incident happened 4 years
ago now as the group was traveling
through Patagonia it was a day almost
identical to the one she was having now
they had been transported by a
helicopter flown by one of the eight
into the middle of the Wilderness there
they had marched for days with without
saying a single word exhaustion had
overtaken her legs and she stumbled to
the ground unfortunately for her this
happened slightly too close to the
female soldier in front of her her knees
hadn't even hit the ground before the
blast went off the woman didn't remember
it of course how could she in an instant
her mind had been utterly destroyed what
she did remember was the next 18 months
as her body slowly healed itself one
brain cell at a time it wasn't so much
like waking up from a nightmare it was
more constructing a nightmare slowly
alongside your Consciousness as neuron
by neuron your brain reformed itself
each individual cell screaming in Terror
at what had happened to it they had her
marching again before she was fit to
move her motor controls had been all
over the place she had fallen over
regularly and the terror of having one
of the soldiers pushed the button again
engulfed her with every movement and yet
Perhaps the most incredible thing about
SCP
0011 was the fact that if you had asked
her if she should have been held in this
kind of containment she would
immediately have agreed without batting
an I the only person capable of opening
the box she recognized how dangerous her
existence was only she had seen into the
mysteries of the Box only she had seen
the horrors laid inside of it and so
only she could fully understand the
gravity of their situation they kept her
on the Move in order to keep the World
safe had she been held in a containment
cell she would have posed too great of a
risk out here in the wilderness the
entire planet was her containment cell
hidden in the middle of Humanity's
biggest hay stack no one not even the 05
council's Central Command knew her
location the only people who were aware
of it at any given time were herself and
the eight soldiers surrounding her with
guns drawn so you can imagine her horror
when out of the Sheets of Rain appeared
the figure of a person carrying a rifle
the gunfire broke out before SCP 00 1-1
even had a chance to hit the ground
bullets whizzed through her hair and
cracked open the Rocks all around her
the eight soldiers surrounding her die
for cover as the figure in the rain
slumped to the ground lifeless one of
the soldiers grabbed the woman by her
explosive collar and threw her behind a
rock clasping her hands over her ears
she closed her eyes and waited for the
fight to be over no one was shooting
until a second figure emerged from the
rain wav ing their arms wildly gunfire
again she wasn't quite sure what had
happened but all of a sudden the woman
was falling down the cliff she had just
been trying to shift her position to get
deeper into cover but she clearly hadn't
noticed just how close to the edge she
was down and down and down she fell
until with a crack in her ankle she
landed in the peep Boog gunfire cracked
on the mountain above her but the only
thought that filled the woman's mind was
the terror that at any moment the
explosive collar around her neck would
be detonated as one of the soldiers
above her realized that she was missing
seconds passed as the fear mounted in
her chest with each passing moment the
anxiety grew more and more crippling she
had to know she had to prepare herself
if it was about to happen she had to use
the machine and look into the future
dragging herself forward through the
muck the woman snatched at the wooden
box it came alive at her touch different
pieces shifted open beneath her fingers
like some kind of elaborate puzzle no
one had taught her how to use this thing
it just happened her fingers would just
dance across its surfaces pushing and
pulling opening and closing twisting and
turning and locking into place until all
of a sudden there it was the box was
wide open in front of her taking a deep
breath and allowing the rain to fall on
her head for another brief moment the
woman leaned forward and stepped into
the box on the trail above her the
gunfire stopped without a word of
communication the soldiers had deafly
flanked the group of people who had
approached them in less than a minute
they neutralized each individual that
came their way in unison the group of
them walked up to the bodies turning
them over to examine their faces they
were nobody's just a group of hikers
lost in the rain what had looked like a
gun turned out to be nothing more than a
walking pull five of them in total none
of them older than 24 without words the
soldiers picked up the body IES and
threw them over their shoulders as they
scrambled their way down to the cliffs
to the woman in the machine beneath them
once they reached the bottom of the
slope they discarded the five bodies
carelessly into the bog within a couple
of hours those five hikers would have
sunk to the bottom and begun the long
process of being embalmed into the
deaths perhaps someone would find them
in a few thousand years time as part of
an archaeological dig perhaps but it was
not their concern the eight soldiers
surrounded the women guns drawn and
stared at her coldly I used the machine
she told them I used it without your
permission I I don't know what the rules
are I don't know if we even have any
rules here but I I thought you should
know the soldiers continued to look at
her in Silence the box was closed now
sitting back on her lap as it always was
I I try to see my future anytime I've
used the Box before I've looked at the
lives of others I've seen economic
crashes climate disasters genocides Wars
love and life and death I've done so at
the hands of the 05 Council as they've
told me given them the information and
prevented the destruction of the world
never once have I looked at my own
future the soldiers lifted her to her
feet and tried to March her onwards not
listening to a word she was saying her
broken ankle buckled and screamed
beneath her she had to hop to keep up
with them what other choice did she have
they would push the button if she didn't
she didn't know why she kept talking but
she did For the First Time The Machine
lied to me I saw that I was assassinated
in 1987 in Cuba it was years before I
even and built the Box before any of
this happened to me I saw in my future
that I no longer existed that the
machine no longer existed but that
future was years ago and none of it
happened the machine doesn't lie so why
is it lying to me now why can't I see my
own future if any of the soldiers were
paying attention they didn't show it
they just continued to March her into
the rain as the bomb weighed heavily
around her neck the man's bedroom hadn't
been silent for over 100 years now the
carpet had been worn down a thick layer
of dust had gathered on every surface
and the same trapped air had stagnated
for so long that it become unbearable
for anyone entering the room but no one
was allowed to enter the room nobody
could open that door ever again or it
could Mark the beginning of not just an
apocalypse but a breakdown in the nature
of reality itself figures shuffled
around the room sometimes dozens
sometimes as few as three all rotting
but never dying researchers peered
through the window in abject Terror day
after day as the laws of physics broke
down before their very eyes all of them
except one a lone scientist with a plan
to get inside that room a plan that the
foundation would shoot him dead for a
plan that he was seconds away from
enacting as the improvised explosive
device in his Satchel clunked heavily
against his thigh in many ways we are
just as trapped as
scp1 if not more so we are trapped in
our own three-dimensional world take a
stick figure drawn on a piece of paper
that stick figure knows up and down left
and right and that is their world you
draw a box around them and they are
trapped unable to Simply step forward
out of the page and walk around it for
us looking down at the stick figure we
might laugh at their foolishness trapped
inside a child's drawing of a house it
begs the question is there a a creature
looking down at us and laughing we may
be able to move up and down left and
right forward and backward outsmarting
the simple stick figure but in time we
are just as caged in living our entire
lives on this razor thin piece of paper
called the present the future is always
just Out Of Reach the past always
repelling us we have no choice but to
exist in the now slowly creeping through
history without any agency of our own
curse to be born Live and Die in that
order you can never be a child again
never see your mother's face for the
first time beaming down at you you
cannot skip ahead to your dying minutes
knowing what it is you will have to face
up to in your life maybe the idea of
facing up to things at all will fade
with the freedom of exploring what once
was and what will be as if it were no
more difficult than taking a step out of
a 2d box the bell rang cutting Professor
Davies off he hadn't meant to go into
such an existential tangent especially
for his first year students most of them
looked like they were in a days not
really listening to anything he had been
saying quantum mechanics sure was a
complex topic to cover in just one
semester at University he'd spent his
entire career trying to wrap his head
around it and still spend most of his
days with the same bored and Confused
glaze over his eyes as the teenagers who
made their way to the back of the hall
but one figure standing just beyond the
doorway peering down at him caught the
professor's eye little did he know how
drastically his career was about to
change in just a few minutes a
preeminent physicist at just 28 years
old Professor Davies had already
achieved the status that many academics
will not see within their lifetimes
whenever anyone asked him about it he
always made the joke that he was
cheating he didn't believe in the
concept of a linear lifetime in the
first place still too young to be taken
seriously by many of his peers he had
flown under the academic radar for much
of his career so far perhaps it was as
simple as that or perhaps certain
undercover agents had a hand in
suppressing news of his blossoming
career in Quantum research his hands
trembled as he approached the reinforced
glass he gripped the bag tightly trying
his best not to let his fear show if any
of them saw what he was about to do if
they even suspected something he would
have a dozen bullets flying through the
back of his skull before he'd even have
a chance to put his hands up shifting
his weight from foot to foot he waited
for the airlock to be open for him a
siren blared red lights flashed and the
first glass door slid open stepping
inside he waited for the atmosphere in
the chamber to adjust both doors were
closed in front of and behind him if
they wanted to kill him now would be the
time he closed his eyes and waited with
baited breath the bomb weighing heavily
on his shoulder but they would not kill
him he knew that now now what he was
about to do was inevitable it took
several months for Professor Davies to
be granted the full security clearance
he needed they kept referring to his
project as a k class anomaly whatever
that meant in order to get him up to
speed with the nature of what he was
going to be working on the foundation
assigned him to various other scps first
SCP 5027 2821 1887 any instance that had
some link to Quantum Mechanics or
complex theoretical physics
they wouldn't even tell him which SCP he
was being trained up to work on until
one morning when a team of Agents was
waiting for him at the door to his
quarters he wasn't allowed to bring a
bag or any personal possessions standard
issue clothing a toothbrush and
everything else he needed would all be
provided for him it was only then that
they told him which SCP he was being
assigned to SCP 001 he was blindfolded
for the entirety of the journey car then
plane then than another car it was a
full 10 hours before his blindfold was
removed and his new project was revealed
to him professor Davies found himself in
site 01 the place where all of this
started all the scps all the research
the secrecy the assassinations the
deaths of countless innocent people and
an equal number of guilty parties it all
started right here site 01 the site
itself resembled a large sarcophagus
similar to the one found covering the
Chernobyl nuclear power plant where do
you think the Soviets got the blueprints
from everything in the room is arranged
in a circle around the center research
desks maintenance equipment raw
materials including a stockpile of
wooden planks and reinforced Metal
Sheets monitoring equipment security
cameras and of course some of the most
advanced automatic weapon systems in the
world all pointed at a great glass box
in the middle of the hanger measuring 30
m in each Direction the glass was 50 cm
thick even all those High Caliber
weapons would have had a hard time
creating a chip in that but it wasn't
the glass box itself that was so
interesting it was what was trapped
inside of it a house inside a perfectly
round glass bowl with no entrances or
exits complete with a front lawn
sidewalk porch and even a tree in the
backyard a regular American house
trapped in a box like some kind of
science experiment there was some kind
of transparent airlock system at the
entrance on the other side was just a
normal walk up the garden path to the
edge of the second glass bubble
enclosing the house but on closer
inspection Professor Davies realized
that this wasn't your typical American
house at all the Street Lamp was an
electric it was made of iron with little
glass painted windows an oil lamp in
fact the house did look odd to him there
was no electric doorbell but instead an
actual physical Bell System the whole
house looked out of place not just
because it was in a box in the central
hanger of a 42,000 ton sarcophagus but
because it was from another era entirely
you see sight 01 was constructed around
this house the glass box and bubble the
sarcophagus all of it was built around
the already existing building beneath
the foundations 100 m beneath the
surface is an immense metal plate that
forms a perfect seal with the defenses
up top the only way in and out of sight
01 is through an immense reinforced door
but even all those defenses will prove
utterly futile if anyone ever opens the
thin wooden door to the bedroom on the
top floor of the house that is the home
and the prison in which SCP 001 is
trapped it is the job of the foundation
to make sure that it remains trapped
there indefinitely what is SCP 00001 as
Professor Davies made his way through
the airlock for the very first time and
entered the site under the the
supervision of four of the highest
ranking SCP staff alive today he laid
eyes on the entity itself for the first
time standing on a scissor lift parked
outside the front of the house just
inches away from the glass bubble it was
lifted high enough to look through the
window into what looked like a young
boy's bedroom on the top floor layers of
dust coated the surfaces black and white
photos sat in frames antique children's
toys sat all around the walls but Davies
didn't notice any of them he was too
busy watching the men walking in all
directions unhurried but with purpose
well over a dozen men walked in all
directions across the carpeted floor
they were all identical around 6 ft with
heavy rotting skin that seemed to hang
off their limbs like it would a carcass
left in the sun human cadavers Milling
about in a young boy's bedroom Davies
was so taken back by their appearance
and behavior that it took him a long
time to notice something truly strange
the reason he was brought here in the
first place they were walking through
the bed in the middle of the room not
just over it or around it but straight
through it as if it wasn't there but
wait something else was wrong too there
weren't 12 of them in the room it was
closer to 20 had he miscounted a moment
ago then he saw it take place one of the
cadavers reached the edge of the room
and paused as if in thought at that
moment it split not in half but rather
two versions of itself emerg from where
one had been standing both walking in
different directions a thrill of
excitement ran through Professor Davy's
body the uncertainty principle it was
there in action in front of him he was
looking at Schrodinger's cat inside the
box and seeing both its corpse and its
living self where uncertainty exists
this entity was somehow embodying both
possibilities in real time he watched
the two selves walk around the room
following different paths for several
minutes until eventually they converged
again back into one being he turned to
the researcher accompanying him lit up
with excitement and asked what they were
doing here the researcher's face was
Grim when he replied they're pacing
waiting the airlock door hissed open he
felt the stale 1800s air hitting his
face perfectly maintained at 20° in
front of him was the Garden Path leading
up to his goal that glass bubble ripping
the satchel he set off up the path slow
enough not to attract any unwarranted
attention over the next few days
Professor Davies learned everything that
the foundation had on SCP 001 it had
been a human once a radical physicist
born in the late 19th century intent on
kickstarting the next Century with a
nuclear Renaissance the young man had
created a working model for stable
nuclear fusion the potential
ramifications were enormous free clean
electricity on a Mass scale with no
harmful byproducts his research was
almost complete when a covert private
military group poisoned him with his own
radioactive nuclear agent the young man
made it back to his house where he died
in his sleep that night powerful
military personnel and prominent
scientists who had been working
alongside the young man knew immediately
what had happened bursting into his home
they were about to walk through his
bedroom door and save him when they saw
the shadow of two feet standing by the
door then another pair the young
scientists had died but he also hadn't
much like Schrodinger's Cat the man was
suspended in a dual state of death and
not death this shocking Discovery led
the group of people present to form a
rudimentary Foundation established to
secure and contain their once friend
within his room never to be discovered
by The Wider world through close
observations since this time it has been
established that SCP 001 exists
independently of linear time in a kind
of superposition relative to the world
around it it is capable of occupying any
space that will or has been empty at any
point in time say you have two chairs in
a room one chair has always been there
the other was added to the room just 5
minutes before the SCP is unable to walk
through the chair that was always there
since it has always existed but the
chair that was added can be passed
through with no problem because there
was a point in time when that chair had
not been there but it also works in the
future if a third chair was present
which had always been there but was
removed 5 minutes after the experiment
SCP 001 could pass through that chair
also the foundation theorizes and hopes
that the start of this clock that SCP
001 operates on was the point at which
the young scientist died and did not die
that is why it is incapable of escaping
its bedroom and that is why it is of
vital importance that the bedroom door
remains closed forever ongoing
maintenance work and preservation
techniques are being employed to keep
the house in as stable of stateus
possible should anything happen to
damage the Integrity of the structure
the quantum chaos contained in that
space could lead to a total breakdown of
the laws of physics destroying not just
the world but the fundamentals of
mathematics as we know them the bomb
bumped against Professor Davy's thigh as
he walked up to the house an old man
whose life had been devoted to denying
the world its future a reality where
what is and what could be are just as
real as one another a world where the
pain of living in the now Fades when you
can travel to any moment in your life
and relive its Joy when you aren't
trapped by the aging process infinite
renewable energy to solve The World's
problems a chance to see your deceased
loved ones again a way to look at the
universe Through The Eyes Of God the
head of 001 containment he had spent his
entire career overriding all of the
safeguards tweaking containment rules
just enough each year also so he could
could walk across this grass with a
satchel on his shoulder and an explosive
more important than the atomic bomb at
his hip he approached the glass of the
inner sphere if he had done the math
right this should do just enough damage
to create a hole in the containment
structure the pressure change wouldn't
be too great inside but it should be
just enough to blow say a bedroom door
wide open SCP 001 is an' 05s tail it
makes sense doesn't it after all
regardless of the exact nature of an SCP
001 proposal there are always certain
things that remain the same see if you
can recall them all well for starters
SCP 001's are all about vital moments
perhaps like the Prototype or the
foundation or the sheath of papers or
the gate Guardian they're about the very
origin of the SCP Foundation itself
perhaps like the ororo cycle or when day
breaks or the world gone beautiful
they're about apocalyptic style
destruction or perhaps the rebirth
perhaps like consensus reality or the
database they are rules or realizations
that changed everything maybe like the
Scarlet king or the black moon or a
simple toy maker they're about the
sparking of great rivalries that truly
Define the backbone of the foundation's
activities another vital element of SCP
001 is always secrecy in classification
they are the most clandestine anomalies
out there generally hidden away below
layer after layer of encryption and
Security even the database for SCP 001
entries is guarded by a mimic kill agent
that'll leave you stoned dead on the
ground if you're below that magical
level five clearance when you attempt to
access it no information is more
carefully and forcefully guarded than
this and of course another vital element
of the SCP 001 entry is deception and
trickery it's inherent to the
designation no other number has multiple
entirely distinct anomalies many of
which either have no correlation with
one another or even actively contradict
each other if you ask some people
they'll tell you that there are multiple
001's because each is of equal
importance in etching the rich portrait
of the foundation's past present and
future some would tell you something
very different there's only one SCP 001
it's a shell game the rest are all fakes
to stop people from taking any single
entry too seriously and thus forever
avoiding the truth some still would tell
you that there is no SCP 001 it's all
just a complex Web of Lies meant to keep
the foundation's enemies and allies in a
state of pliable ignorance if an
intimate knowledge of the SCP
foundation's past and inner workings a
commitment to secrecy at all costs and a
love of deception as a tool for control
all sound familiar it's because they're
the favorite toolkit of a certain group
we're all familiar with the 05 Council
the very top brass of the SCP Foundation
it only makes sense that if anyone knew
the truth about the fractured and
strange SCP 01 it would be them the more
observant among you may have noticed a
certain emission from many popular SCP
001 entries we've Nam dropped in this
video so far and it is no accident that
this particular SCP 001 entry is the
only one straight from the mouth of 05-
one the founder of the council himself
it is the factory it is a strange and
sorid Tale Of Violence horror and dark
Bargains made with truly unknowable
forces it's a tale that tells us about
the initial creation and growth of the
foundation the event that nearly
destroyed it and an indication as to the
dark future possibly in store it's a
little bit of everything you can expect
from a good 001 proposal and surely if
this is the SCP 001 entry that the head
of the council swear by then it must be
the definitive entry into the 001 Cannon
right well not quite because as you're
about to find out not even the 05
Council itself can really reach a
consensus on the true nature of the
fascinating and much-feared Factory but
perhaps through hearing every side of
this particularly dark story we can find
the kernels of Truth hidden somewhere in
the middle of it all but of course be
warned as with all things when it comes
to the 05 Council it's going to get
extremely weird but before we move on to
what the rest of the 05 Council have to
say about the factory it would be
prudent to refresh our memory on 0-1
version of the story The version that
has been considered to be absolute
before we pour into the equally strange
stories of the other council members it
began with a wealthy industrialist and
thoroughly evil man named James Anderson
all the way back in
1835 when the United States was still
new and finding its feet Anderson was an
engine of unchecked ambition malice and
most of all truly boundless greed he
wanted everything and more and being a
true businessman down to the core he was
willing to make whatever deal he needed
to make in order to see himself become
an even wealthier man that's why like a
lot of bored rich people in his day he
began dabbling in the dark arts for Fun
and Profit until eventually he made
contact with a benefactor on the other
side under these instructions James
Anderson built the factory a truly
magnificent and terrible feat of
architecture and engineering for the
time a multi-level townsed complex that
could produce everything from food to
weapons to toys to textiles to precious
metals and so much more workers could
find room and board at this Grand
Factory and pay for it with their labor
for the wouldbe workers of an unsteady
early America Anderson seemed like a
saint people flocked from all over the
the country to live and work in the
factory but once they were locked behind
the Factory's doors they realized that
James Anderson was no saint he was as
bad or worse than any devil he served
the inside of the factory was a
torturous nightmare where people were
regularly worked to death and then
ground into meat that was sold off all
across the country Anderson kept a
brutal guard Force to beat down anyone
resisting or not working hard enough
those who weren't worked to death or EX
uted by the guards for some petty
infraction could potentially have an
even worse fate in store for them being
dragged off and subjected to occult
experiments by Anderson these people
wouldn't be killed but they would live
as humans no more Anderson was able to
keep the factory and its nightmarish
activities running and under wraps for
decades all the way into the Civil War
it was only when a beaten bloody starved
and traumatized worker managed to escape
and alert president ulyses S Grant of
the mistreat treatment going on inside
that something was done about it this is
where 051 and a progenitor of the SCP
Foundation would get involved there was
a small but Elite group of Union
Soldiers commissioned by President Grant
to work behind the Confederate lines
specializing in tackling the strange and
Supernatural down south this group of
course was led by 05- one considering
some of the reports of anomalous
Supernatural activity going on behind
the closed doors of the Anderson Factory
Grant new knew that these would be the
men to send on this vital Mission and
president Grant's faith in these men was
rewarded though it wasn't an easy fight
they were able to infiltrate and defeat
the forces of the factory they fought
their way through Anderson's sadistic
guards through his menagerie of
terrifying homemade monsters and
eventually they got to Anderson himself
they were so appalled by the horrors
they'd seen inside the factory they
couldn't stop themselves from torturing
Anderson to death and dismember
remembering his corpse they freed the
trapped workers and rooted out whatever
remained of Anderson's forces within the
building however this is where they made
their first pivotal decision rather than
simply destroying the sworded place and
leaving it as Rubble they instead
decided to utilize it and the many
anomalous objects that It produced this
became the foundation of the foundation
over time their organization grew and
the 05 Council was formed they began
spreading their influence and capturing
anomal Poli all over this was however
until they engaged in a bloody war with
the superior military forces of the Fay
despite their augmented weaponry and
tools from the factory when the Fay
performed an allout assault against them
they were decimated in his greatest
shame 05- one fled the battlefield into
the bowels of the factory as his friends
and allies were slaughtered by the Fay
behind him eventually after locking
himself in a room with an ornate door he
encountered the true demonic heart of
the factory using Anderson's dismembered
corpse as a mouthpiece 0 5-1 struck a
terrible deal with the factory they
wiped out the Fay entirely and reversed
all the damage they had done the SCP
Foundation grew beyond the factory and
eventually covered it in rubble out of
shame but the factory wasn't done it is
still very much alive and Furious at
being betrayed it will keep producing
deadly anomalous objects and creatures
and releasing them out into the World
until the foundation pays what it owes
in full and the occasional sacrifice
d-class researcher and guard won't cut
it forever or at least that's how 05-
oneill story but can it really be called
a complete one we wanted to find out for
ourselves which is why we asked every
other member of the 05 Council to tell
their side of the Factory's tale these
are 12 tales about a factory
his throat and made the admission that
in truth the factory came back with him
as it turns out
[Music]
his bizarre new condition was to help
better the future with his knowledge one
piece of technology he brought back was
a hyper advaned piece of technology
known as a nanofactory which as the name
suggests is a machine that uses Nanobots
to construct pretty much anything like
the ultimate futuristic 3D printer it
resulted in the creation of a huge
number of futuristic items that helped
the SCP Foundation along in their
mission to secure contain and protect
including amnestics however what
05-25-18
happen in reality as we know it it
happened in cyberspace he and his
colleagues were very interested in the
matrixes Journey of downloading their
minds into computers back in the day
both for practical reasons and to play
extremely immersive games of Doom
however one day something fundamentally
changed a new Consciousness was born in
then Soviet Russia 05-30 two of his
companions all operating in cyberspace
went to go check it out along with a few
helpful AI constructs eventually they
discovered it an ever expanding data
packet that would transform into a
powerful artificial Consciousness known
as the factory with mysterious motives
and seemingly malicious intent something
it more than proved when it erased the
mind of one of 053 companions killing
him since this incident the factory has
only gotten more powerful its motus
operandi is affecting machines in the
real world and causing them to produce
anomalous items which then become the
SCP foundation's latest problems to deal
with 05- four seemed both Twitchy and
indignant when the topic was brought up
they lamented the fact that the
foundation hadn't put more research into
the factory and how to stop it because
technically it is their most dangerous
and mysterious enemy group of interest
05- for explained it as follows the FBI
unusual incident unit is a joke are we
cool yet is just a bunch of pretentious
privileged rich kids Marshall Carter and
dark limited only care about money and
thus can be bought off the global occult
Coalition often helps them take care of
more challenging anomalies the Church of
the broken God and the sarcs are often
too busy waging Petty religious wars
against each other to do real meaningful
damage to the SCP Foundation Prometheus
Labs had already fallen and Dr Wonder
tainment wouldn't Thrive forever the
factory however was a truly unknown
quantity it's just out there somewhere
pumping out anomalies that soon become
everyone else's very dangerous problem
05- for personally resented that the
foundation and their fellow council
members don't see this and allocate more
resources to the cause because someday
soon it might really come back to bite
them as these things often do 0 5-5 was
considerably bitter as in they denied
that the factory ever even existed
claiming that the SCP Foundation made it
up to cover up a bunch of anomalies that
they themselves had created and then
told us to um f off if you know what I
mean some people get so hostile when you
just want simple answers next came the
tale of 0 5-6 which came in the form of
a World War II Espionage anecdote of
course this was also during the height
of the 7th occult war and Hitler
assisted by the fuel society and obscura
corpse was trying to get his GRE little
hands on as many anomalies as possible
in hopes of turning the tide of the war
in his favor 0 5-6 was working
undercover Behind Enemy Lines disguised
as an SS officer as he slowly helped
dismantle Hitler's anomalous offensive
from within he'd heard whisperings of
the Nazis developing a weapon unlike any
other a factory that would produce
anomalies for them on demand and give
them the supernatural Edge -6 didn't
believe it at first until he was
attacked by a group of vicious living
Punch and Judy dolls created by the
factory he nearly managed to survive the
Ambush but seemed Disturbed in
recounting the fact that when he
destroyed the dolls they bled profusely
eventually the leads he was following
led him to a ruin at the base of Zug
swootz inside he discovered the ruin was
Hollow and filled with floating Stone
orbs producing energy that allowed the
Theo Society researchers to produce more
anomalies 0 5-6 was able to destroy this
anomaly Factory but he took a souvenir
SCP 627 a little Stone ball that rolls
around on the ground when it comes into
contact with people 057 admitted
somewhat sheepishly that while there was
technically no real physical factory
factory product anomalies are real and
they're all his fault he purchased a
bunch of random items from Walmart and
printed a fake logo for the factory on
the back his plan was to give these
totally innocent objects to Junior
researchers both to mess with them for
fun and to test their critical thinking
skills however it turned out that simply
placing this logo onto an item results
it in becoming an anomalous item
admittedly it was rough for 057 to have
to follow the cool story about fighting
magic Nazis 0 5-8 made the far more
exciting claim that the factory is
actually all the way up on the moon back
when the SCP Foundation were first
founding Moonbase Alpha they discovered
that some ancient and unknown
civilization had already built a covert
base under the surface it was a
storehouse of anomalous alien technology
the first 13 people to enter were
immediately vaporized by the laser
defense system but the fourth to enter
was given an even worse fate he was
pulled into the machine and fused with
it at which point the factory was truly
activated it began to produce anomalies
and transport them to random locations
all across the globe and it's been a
problem ever since when we spoke to 05-
9 on the matter with a Steely look in
his eye he simply muttered the word
Atlantis no further comments were made
on the matter 05-10 explained that the
factory was a single man a truly ancient
and Brilliant anomalous Craftsman that
they found in a Mountain Temple in Tibet
he was taken by the foundation and
contained but given far more high-tech
tools to work his magic so they could
keep reaping the anomalous fruits of his
labors however the craft man was
appropriately crafty and managed to
produce a duplicate of himself to
distract the foundation while he made an
escape he's still out there to the stay
making more anomalies a one-man Factory
05-11 claimed that the factory was alien
in origin but it wasn't on the moon it
was the true explanation for the iconic
1947 Roswell New Mexico UFO incident a
flying saucer descended and offered
05-11 who was the commander of the
response team at the time the most
wonderful things this saucer became the
factory but humanity and 05-11 were
deceived it wasn't long before this
extraterrestrial Factory was producing
countless deadly anomalous nightmares
the world over with nothing we could do
about it 05-12 said that the factory is
a mess it's a remnant of the
foundation's attempt to erase the
supernatural from Human belief
Foundation researchers claim that due to
the inherent power in human belief the
belief in the Supernatural gave it power
and phasing Humanity as a whole out of
this belief was a major factor in making
sure things weren't much worse than they
are today however some hearty things
slip through the cracks and because
reality has a strange sense of humor
these things are marked with the logo of
the factory to round things off we have
a bonus take from the mysterious
05-13 who was instrumental in helping us
put the rest of this video together he
claims that he created the factory and
that it acts as a a kind of
countermeasure against interdimensional
Invaders while it may seem like the
factory is creating anomalies it's
actually intercepting them and making
them safer some anomalies that seem to
come from the factory may be dangerous
but if 05-13 is to be believed then
they'd be a hell of a lot more dangerous
if the factory wasn't here and there you
have it folks the story of the factory
from every possible angle even though it
feels like each angle is facing in an
entirely different direction in the
world of Oprah Winfrey so what is the
truth is there a nugget of reality
beneath all of the fallacy or do you
think the 05 Council was trolling all of
us for even daring to ask we leave that
question to you dear viewers let us know
which Theory you believe down in the
comments below They Came From Beyond the
world from over the world from under the
world they came from inside the stars
and from behind the rain they came from
the known lands and they came from the
secret places of old the vast ones who
drank of the nebula the small ones who
did not care what happened beyond the
banks of their Rivers the ones who
bathed in the light and the ones who
watched from the Shadows the ones who
loved us and the ones who forgot about
us the ones who hate us now and the ones
who love us still the ones who sung with
the rats and the ones who swam with the
leviathans they came from far and near
they came one and all they came to end
the world as you may already know from
our previous video in this series a
mysterious being known only as the
harbinger unlocked SCP 001 the lock and
brought about the omn apocalypse every
single World destroying XK class
scenario on the books from Foundation
files to the most ancient mythological
Toms and some we'd never even imagin
began to come true true a world flooded
with terrifying anomalous activity from
unfurling Skies to Giant nightmarish
animals was about where we left off now
it's time to open your eyes and wake up
this is the kind of nightmare you can't
encounter while you're asleep SCP 5720
the astronomically inclined crane went
about its daily work the small
mechanical crane always occupied itself
with the one task that gave its
existence any meaning arranging esoteric
model solar systems but something was
different today SCP 5720 put the final
touches on its latest model and then
lifted its mechanical arms skywards
pointing directly into the vast and
Starry Infinity above but were they
Stars no not today as SCP 5720 looked up
at the sky this time the sky looked back
they weren't Stars they were eyes
something was coming towards Earth from
the furthest reaches of the outer door
dark an armada of world Enders coming
from above below and all around a whole
Cosmos of supremely powerful beings
zeroing in on our pale blue dot a
thought crossed through whatever passed
as the mind of this strange Little Crane
today is the day your prayers will be
answered followed by another word
ringing loud and clear and holy as a
mighty church bell
awaken and at that that moment
everything did thousands of miles away a
new God landed on Earth appearing like a
great wall of dense matted fur
descending from the sky Ur Anum the
mother of the ones that came before
after eons of absence she had eventually
returned to greet her children the true
rulers and stewards of this land but an
Anum was surprised and horrified by what
she saw their great cities their
sprawling structures their beauti
beautiful art and advanced culture all
gone laid to waste by the worthless
hairless Apes that once lurked in the
forests with the other animals something
had happened something had changed the
humans had slaughtered her people
destroyed their accomplishments
tarnished their legacy driven the few
that were left out of Their Kingdoms and
into the forests treated them as mere
animals and built their hideous concrete
cities over their bones and they had the
G to call them Bigfoot or SCP 1000
because thanks to them their beautiful
true name had been lost to time she
looked skywards and cried out in Despair
and anguish at the loss of her children
inconsolable but then she felt something
a glimmer of hope in her mind the
possibility that things would change
that the humans would be toppled from
their Thrones and True Justice would be
achieved she called out to her remaining
children and her her children answered
across the globe another great entity
awoke deep underneath a mountain when it
stirred into life and broke free it
shattered the entire Mountain on top of
it as easily as you or me displacing a
bed sheet it took to the skies massive
but unseeable to the human eye it soared
through the air gazing down upon the
world it hadn't seen for thousands of
years once it had feasted on the blood
sacrifices of human subjects hoping to
avoid its wrath but hum weren't the
petty little group of huddled cavemen
that they had once been now they were in
their billions gathered in impossibly
large settlements The Entity sought to
find a seed of power that it could
influence but now it was spoiled for
Choice eventually it zeroed in and found
its perfect Target an SCP Foundation
containment site here it would find a
new form to take and more Petty pathetic
humans to bring under its Mighty thw it
landed in SCP 765 five the duck pond it
is an anomalous Pond that is you guessed
it full of ducks and initially induces
feelings of Serenity and its victims
before later inducing not so pleasant
feelings when the entity plummeted into
the water it began to absorb and bond
with the anomaly growing to Epic sizes
as it assumed a form that the minds of
us feeble humans could comprehend a
giant terrifying duck it released a
mighty earthshaking quack as it plotted
across the countryside to cause Mayhem
elsewhere in Europe more violent Madness
was unfolding a crimson rooster C than a
Golden Rooster and then a rooster of
soot red anyone with the basic knowledge
of Norse mythology was shaking in their
boots as a mighty Beast stirred in the
heart of a desolate cave the chains that
had once held the Monstrous dog in place
now broke it Rose and licked its Jagged
fangs excited to stain them with the
blood of its enemies it was the great
hound fener omen of of the end times
here to Herald the end of all things a
trumpet boomed across the globe with no
Apparent Source people in the streets in
New York delh London Cape Town and
countless other towns cities and hamlets
the world over paused and listened in
confusion below them the great and
terrible jangad the thought to be
mythological midgard serpent stirred
from its previously Eternal Slumber and
began to uncoil its body the shifting
earthquakes and tsunamis along the coast
of Greenland as towns and Villages
crumbled killing thousands fener stalked
along the length of Denmark slaughtering
and devouring anyone or anything unlucky
enough to cross its path but it did not
wage its war against mankind alone
behind it a hellish Army of burning
Giants marched Mighty hands clutching
molten weapons Ragnarok was upon us now
Odin save us all and the administrator
slept she was the latest in a long line
of foundation staff members to hold that
hollowed position and in the dark vistas
of her dreams a predecessor approached
her he wasn't the old bearded man in the
heavy coat that she remembered now he
was wearing a 1950 suit and a fedora hat
and carrying a briefcase that's right
he'd taken up the mantle of SCP 990 also
known as the dreamman he's a mysterious
figure that appears to members of the
foundation in their dreams warning them
of impending disasters that they may be
able to barely prevent if his warning is
heed though it often comes at some
terrible cost to the recipient of his
message this time however his message
carried a different tone he told the
current administrator that there was no
way to stop the apocalypse from
occurring this time only making sure
that the particular shape of the
Apocalypse would be the one most
favorable to the foundation and
Humanity's joint interests all this was
devastating news that the new
administrator saw as a grievous betrayal
of both the foundation stances and
Humanity as a whole she refused to
accept the idea that the apocalypse was
inevitable even coming from the mouth of
a former administrator as far as she was
concerned this dream man no longer
worked on the side of the foundation he
was in League with the world Enders and
she refus to take his deal the SCP
Foundation would save this world from
the horrors the lock Unleashed or they
would slide into the darkness with it
they would never work against the human
race SCP 343 also known as God awoke in
his cell in sight 17 the time for fun
and games with the humans at the
foundation had come and gone he was
going by his true name Yahweh now he
blinked and in that same instant he was
at site zero the containment site for
another SCP 001 the legendary gate
Guardian all the staff around them
looked upon Yahweh in shock AED by the
reality warper sudden appearance and
unable to do anything about it but
really 343 was no mere reality Warfare
like some had expected 343 truly was a
God he just didn't happen to be the only
one in play When the gate Guardian saw
Yahweh now standing before him he
lowered his sword spread his fiery wings
and took a knee in great reverence
Yahweh spoke calmly but with unshakable
authority yuel it is time open the gate
lead my armies across the Earth the gate
Guardian Uriel responded Ed in its
booming voice I he and
oy my Lord and
my for the first time in recorded memory
the grand gate that yuriel had always
been guarding opened revealing thousands
of Legions of warrior Angels waiting on
the other side they were impossibly
beautiful and Powerful creatures each
one of vibrant glowing chaos of wings
and eyes wielding Pure White sword
swords and singing resounding hymns of
War soon the air was thick with a chorus
of rustling wings as the Angels loosened
themselves from the gates mouth led by
Uriel as yahweh's general into the
global fry meanwhile back at Sait 10
another SCP 001 the item that started
all of this the lock was entering its
next stage of grand Cosmic Evolution
something within the lock suddenly
unfurled causing a shock wave that
killed everyone at the site and
destroying the entire building in an
instant except in that same instant all
of the site 10 staff and the building
itself reappeared completely unharmed in
a field in New Hampshire back where
saiten used to be the lock was doing
some terraforming the ground split open
beneath into a mighty Valley the likes
of which Earth had never seen before
Lush Greenery sprouted within and
thousands of strange alien creatures
soon populated this new place in in the
center the lock just floated in place
they were now ready for the first
meeting to take place over at site 2036
Dr Everett man was working on a number
of SCP 098 specimens these are
frightening creatures reminiscent of
spider crabs with blades instead of
Pinchers and a natural ability to mimic
the sounds of their prey he was studying
the creatures when he got a call asking
him if the specimens had acted up at all
they had already had sudden containment
breaches for SCP 99 5 a type of
dangerous carnivorous fungi and SCP 616
a mysterious airplane with satanic
elements to it just as Dr man was about
to reply the 098 specimens
metamorphosized into many wied flying
creatures which flew out of the chamber
with such force that they busted through
walls Sirens blared all through the
facility and Dr man joined the many
other confused and frustrated Foundation
staff members wandering the building
wondering just what the hell was going
on today they were were getting bizarre
reports of unprecedented anomalous
activity from all over the world with no
explanation uniting at all according to
paniced Whispers across the facility
emergency order Patmos was now in effect
whatever that meant the true nature of
what was going on here went over most of
the heads of the SCP foundation's staff
that's when man encountered Dr Charles
Ogden gears who for such a famously
emotionless man looks surprisingly
worried Dr man tried to downplay the
situation saying they were only looking
at a handful of containment breaches
here nothing they hadn't handled before
Dr gears shut him down with trademark
coldness feeling a little more nervous
now Dr Everett man asked what else had
gotten out with Steely eyes Dr gears
replied a whole damn lot hour one there
is only one news story on every website
newspaper and TV screen the flowers are
blooming everywhere all across the globe
every country every land mass the bitter
cold of the Antarctic gives way to a
glowing rainbow of petals the Sahara
Desert and Death Valley become beacons
of thriving Technicolor plant life the
highest mountains the lowest valleys the
darkest caves the flowers even burst
free from the concrete of cities as if
reminding us that really it was never
our world we were only borrowing it and
today our lease is up this is SCP
001 object class unnecessary it was
foretold by Tails from other dimensions
a distant future coming down the tracks
towards us and today the train has
reached the station nobody's reporting
on how the economy or the stock market
is doing today no point celebrity
scandals have faded away into
nothingness greedy businessmen lying
politicians brutal tyrants none of them
are making the headlines today the very
last headlines the world gone beautiful
and what a shame it takes the end of it
all to make us realize what really
matters to us that's right you're
looking at the end of the world but it's
okay don't panic take a deep breath in
and out it was bound to happen
eventually so no point worrying now even
the foundation knows that this just
isn't something they can stop so instead
of asking things like how can we prevent
this or do we have any final Tricks Up
Our Sleeve let's ask a different
question entirely what would you do if
you knew that you only had 24 hours
until all life on Earth ends think hard
after all even if you never live to see
the flowers bloom a final day will still
come for you just as it does for us all
hour six a d-class sits alone in his
cell when he sees the flowers growing
out of the ground normally he'd assume
that this meant he was in some kind of
foundation experiment but not today
everyone on Earth had an innate sense
that the time is now a kind of gallows
calm spreads out over everyone and
everything it's over and that's okay we
all knew it was going to happen
eventually right he size and gives a
slight smile those flowers sure are
beautiful that's when he hears footsteps
outside his cell approaching a key
slides into his cell door and opens
there stands Dr gears holding a bottle
of wine and two glasses anyone who knows
him might think he's been replaced by
some kind of shape-shifting anomaly or
had his mind taken over by a powerful
Cognito Hazard but now it's him the
famously cold Dr Charles Ogden gears Dr
gears says come on it's a lovely day out
there it'd be a terrible waste to spend
the whole thing cooped up in here here
it'd feel like a trick on any day but
this the d-class nods and follows the
doctor out the normally oo stoic
Foundation senior researcher pours
himself in the d-class each a glass of
wine and asks What's Your Name by the
way I don't think I ever checked the
d-class replies that his name is Harold
the two smile and Shad as they exit the
now empty d-class containment Wing
everyone else is outside already
researchers guards administrative staff
and DCL classes all rubbing elbows
enjoying the beautiful sun on their last
day together Elsewhere on site a flock
of SCP 514 is released just as identical
flocks are being released from every
containment site all over the world
they've prepared it all for this very
day SCP 54 is a special breed of homing
pigeons created by the Mana charitable
Foundation which have the power to
suppress aggression for those within
their field of anomalous influence and
now millions of them are flying all over
the world after all there's no point
fighting on a day like this there is no
future left to secure people always told
them there would forever be hope until
the flowers bloomed no situation was
ever truly over until the World Went
beautiful but in the absence of Hope
there was something even more inviting
total absolute calm the site 19
Personnel sit together and watch the
flowers bloom hour 12 all militaries
call a global ceasefire soldiers from
opposing sides hug and shake hands in
Flowery fields that once seemed choked
by death and blood borders fade bitter
rivalries turn to dust Korea unifies all
is quiet in the Middle East gangsters
and drug cartels drop their weapons and
return home to their families and
friends as flocks of SCP 514 Fly Above
what good is all the blood money in the
world on a day like this wardens walk
cell to cell through all the world's
prisons granting people their freedom
again sometimes after lifetimes of not
having it they taste the air again feel
the sun on their face they close their
eyes drink it in and walk among the
flowers free men locations of Marshall
Carter and dark limited close their
doors and shutter their Windows
worldwide for the first time in as long
as any of them can remember they turned
their signs to closed they've earned a
day off everyone has the chaos insurgent
rolls up their plans and burns them they
drop their weapons and throw away their
tactical gear as they do so they can't
help but question themselves what was it
all for in the end what was any of it
for all the fighting in Bloodshed and
death we did it day after day only to do
it again the next day what silly reasons
we killed and died for what silly
reasons indeed the global cult Coalition
dismisses its staff thanking them for
their service and telling them to go
spend their last hours with the ones
they love like the foundation they
accept that this is the one true Final
End no ritual to stop no monster to
fight no evil extradimensional entity to
thwart just go outside and smell the
flowers while you still can the
Serpent's hand are similar they decide
after decades fighting a losing battle
they'll spend their last day in The
Wanderers library reading some of their
favorite volumes all these wonderful
stories now left for other Earths to
read their own stories would be counted
among them in the end and they take
great comfort in that in a sense
everyone will live forever in the pages
of the books in the wanderer's library
Herman Fuller's circus of the
disquieting releases all of its Freaks
and clowns from their Twisted grasp to
go and live out whatever small dreams
and Tiny Pleasures they could find over
their last hours they have no Foundation
of fear anymore nobody Minds their
strange appearances and odd behaviors
why would anyone waste such a beautiful
day judging others on the last day on
Earth there's nothing left to prove
sarcas sys dropped their ancient flesh
bound Toms and acolytes of the broken
God put down their gilded blades on the
slopes of Siberia the jungles of Peru
and the most isolated beaches of Mexico
Twisted flesh finally touch living metal
in the spirit of husbandry their Eternal
war is at its and in the face of the
blooming World they didn't seem so
different after all the Agents of the
doctor Wonder tainment Corporation
predictably chose to spend their last
hours sitting around and playing with
toys together time well spent if you ask
us in a highly secretive location
perhaps the most heavily secured place
in the entire world the 13 members of
the legendary 05 Council decide to just
sit and talk anyone who knows anything
about this secretive cabal can tell you
the 05 Council has spent a considerable
portion of their very very long lives
trying to figure out ways to dodge and
cheat death but now facing a death they
can't Dodge the same calm washing over
the rest of the world has finally
reached them too all they can really
think this time is well played reaper
well played as they chat about the kind
of aan casual things that they haven't
had time to discuss in years 0 5-3
suggests inviting the Ethics Committee
over to join nobody disagrees hour 16 it
isn't just the DCL classes all Sapient
and non-aggressive scps have been
released from containment free to spend
the last of their time as they wish tens
of thousands of anomalous individuals
are released from containment sites all
over the globe it'd be the greatest
victory that the Serpent's hand could
ever ask for if they weren't all too
busy reading to notice SCP 105 Iris
Thompson finally returns to her parents
the Foundation had fed them the lie that
their daughter had died many years
before but as Iris had a tendency to do
she was ready to work a miracle her
parents Embrace her with open arms
they'll spend their last hours together
catching up on what's happened since
they parted ways and making up for lost
time they couldn't be happier SCP 1867
Lord Blackwood the Fantastical sea snail
is delivered into a warm Rock pool near
the site where he was being contained
there he might finally have one more
Grand Adventure before all is said and
done though afterward he may not have
the time to tell anyone about it a
terrible shame really because nobody
spins a yarn like Lord Blackwood the
non-aggressive little misters Run free
Mr Fish eagerly returns to his native
Boston Massachusetts where he enjoys one
more Lobster sandwich before the end of
the world Mr hedless decides to go hat
shopping because he wants to look good
for the apocalypse Mr lost finally
Settles down for the afternoon deciding
that just this once he's earned himself
a rest SCP 2800 cactusman returns to
Edinburgh to spend his last days picking
up litter and helping old ladies cross
the street SCP 3663 the tunnel monster
walks the streets of his hometown
searching for an old friend hoping to
reunite before it all ends SCP 073 Kane
decides to take a walk outside for the
first time in thousands of years he
can't help but Smile as the bright
colorful life beneath his feet is
growing faster than his presence can
kill it what a truly beautiful day
knowing that there's no longer time for
Colts to form and bother him SCP 2662
cthulu decides to take a break from his
intense Minecraft session and go take a
walk outside it feels so good to have
the sun on his tentacles once more and
to feel the lush green grass under his
suction cups he shakes his head thinking
once again about the irritating Colts
that had been pestering him for decades
what kind of idiot would want him to
destroy a world like this SCP 343 also
known as God sze and looks over all his
creation for what he knows to be the
last time his mouth curls into a smile
as he thinks well we had a pretty good
run still in a Cell SCP 049 the plague
doctor puts his feet up and decides to
relax the pestilence will soon be taken
care of on some animalistic level below
thought below even Instinct scp096 feels
grateful that no gaze will ever fall
upon it again somewhere fizzling in a
vat of acid within a highly secure
containment chamber SCP 682 is feeling
for the first time in its hellish
existence a sense of profound relief the
pain the hate the rage the constant
termination attempts it all be over soon
hour 23 people Gather in the streets
they laugh and dance and sing as the
moon shines fat and white far above deep
in their hearts they quietly contemplate
the end of all of this but why worry why
spoil the fun there's no future left to
worry about strangers become as close as
family in the end human or otherwise
anomalous or non-anomalous chaos
Insurgency agents have last suppers with
ex Serpent's hands and Geo operatives
there is no hate left no violence No
Malice no cruelty the greatest tragedy
in all of this is that it took the
ultimate end to bring it out in people
but why worry why worry seconds pass
then minutes the world buzzes it hums
trillions of creatures doing everything
they'd wanted even though it won't last
in the face of the true end the world
has never been more alive hour 24
silence forever and ever and ever good
night we'll end this video the way it
began by putting a question to you how
would you spend your last 24 hours on
Earth let us know down in the comments
because it'll happen to all of us
eventually say kids would you like to
hear a story cuz we've got a really good
one for you seriously you're going to
love it it's a classic rag to his tale
about one man's rise from humble
beginnings to become one of History's
Greatest and most Visionary toy makers
or maybe it isn't maybe it's about a
company that literally came from nothing
whose Origins are still shrouded in
mystery maybe it's about a woman
breaking the glass ceiling to take over
the toy company left to her by her
eccentric father maybe it's about all of
these things but the one thing we can
tell you about the story of Dr Wonder
tainment is that every word of it is
true or at least as far as anything is
true in the weird wonderful world of the
SCP Foundation as long as you believe
we'll all have a wonderful time as long
as you believe nothing can hurt you not
in the fabulous world of Dr Wonder
tainment Dr Wonder tainment is the name
given to SCP 001 who due to his
relatively benign Nature has been
classified as safe by the the foundation
rather than focusing on containing
Wonder tainment himself the SCP
Foundation has centered its efforts on
containing the products that he creates
he is a Class one reality warper capable
of constructing otherwise normal objects
and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially dangerous toys
in games that are distributed by as yet
unknown means many of Wonder tainment
tour boys are in The foundation's
Possession such as SCP 445 origami paper
that takes on properties of whatever
it's folded to look like and SCP 3147
lollipops that allow people to switch
voices with each other Dr Wonder
tainment was born into a family of
humble means his mother was a seamstress
and his father was an accountant
unsatisfied with his mundane life Wonder
tainments only joy growing up was in the
stories that his father would tell him
about an an ancestor of his who was once
a famous toy maker inspired by these
stories Wonder tainment developed an
interest in crafting toys and as an
adult set out to learn the secrets he
would need to create toys unlike
anything the world had ever seen he
spent his life following rumors of
magical artifacts and Enchanted trinkets
until his search brought him to a
mysterious Factory if you've seen our
previous videos on SCP 001 proposals you
can probably guess that this Factory was
the Factory The Mysterious place where
new scps are supposedly created Wonder
tment barely escaped the massacre and
the foundation takeover of the factory
with his life but he was able to find a
variety of notes that he took with him
these notes contained clues that led him
to the workshop of his famous toy maker
ancestor and from there he reclaimed his
Birthright that was the day that he
truly became doctor Wonder tainment it's
a fun story isn't it very
straightforward but perhaps it is a
little underwhelming for an SCP 001
proposal after all SCP 001 is the
collective designation given to some of
the most important anomalies of all time
including many that could have
potentially been involved in the
foundation's very founding H let's start
again Reginald filbert lonol archal
Westinghouse wondertainment III is the
name given to SCP 001 who due to his
highly unpredictable Nature has been
classed as uid by the foundation and he
is to be detained as soon as his
location can be ascertained until he can
be captured the SCP Foundation has
focused its efforts on containing the
products that he creates he is a Class 2
reality warper capable of constructing
otherwise normal objects and imbuing
them with anomalous properties he's
become infamous for using this ability
to create bizarre magical and
potentially dangerous toys games candies
soft drinks and other products aimed at
children and young teens these products
are distributed by as yet unknown means
many of Wonder tainments Creations are
in Foundation possession such as the
often imitated but never matched little
misters collection which are a group of
living Collectibles with unique
anomalous properties due to
entertainment's reality warping
abilities it is impossible possible to
pin down concrete information about his
history what we can tell you for sure is
that he's Immortal and ageless and comes
from a long line of Wonder tainment
stretching all the way back to the
Cretaceous Period where they made all
sorts of toys for the good little
dinosaur children it's also widely known
that he is in fact not a real person but
merely the manifestation of the dreams
of every child on Earth brought forth
solely by the power of imagination no
confirmed sighting of Dr Wonder tainment
have ever occurred but Witnesses have
described him as dashing very handsome
for his age and a lovely chap capable of
creating Whimsy and wonder with the snap
of his fingers he's a tall man about the
height of a piece of string and he's
immediately recognizable by his walking
stick and w-shaped mustache it's also
been reported that he has scarring
around the circumference of both wrists
almost as if his hands have been removed
and reattached at some point however the
truth of the matter is that
h no no we're telling it all wrong again
this doesn't do anything to capture the
scope of the wonderment story it needs
to feel bigger more comprehensive let's
try it again Dr wonderment is a
trademark of the Wonder tainment toy
company the name given to SCP 001 a
corporation that due to its consistent
output of anomalous items is classed by
the foundation as ker until this company
can be permanent ly shut down the SCP
Foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that it creates
the collective power of the company's
constituent employees and the technology
they make use are equivalent to that of
a class 3 reality warper the
wondertainment company produces and
sells a range of products ranging from
the seemingly normal to the downright
weird all imbued with anomalous
properties the company has become
infamous for their constant output of
bizarre magical and potentially d
dangerous toys games candies soft drinks
and other products aimed at children
teens and young ate heart adults these
products are made and distributed from
Wonderworld trademark a location that is
yet unknown to the foundation but offers
factory tours every hour from Tuesday to
Friday many of Wonder tainment Creations
are in Foundation possession such as
Wonder tainment famous Dragon snails the
real fire breathing pet you can keep in
your pocket not much is known about the
inner workings of the wonderment company
the SCP Foundation has no information
currently on the company's leadership
structure location history or corporate
policies various former and current
employees have been interviewed
regarding their experiences working for
wondertainment but they never seem to be
able to remember very much of use those
interviewed variously describe the
Wonder tainment company as a regular
office building an immense Toy Factory
an amusement park but all agree it's the
best place they ever worked in fact you
should apply for for a job there we I I
mean they have a few openings in their
legal department or so I've heard oh
silly me it seems we've gotten off topic
you're here to hear about the SCP 001
proposal posting a job ad wasn't what I
meant to do when I hacked
into I mean well don't worry about that
forget I said a thing now let's try this
again but this time we'll add a Twist
Isabelle Helga Anastasia PVA Wonder
tainment the 5 is the name given to SCP
001 who due to her ability to spread
sunshine and Whimsy wherever she goes
has been classed as Thal by the
foundation and due to her immensely
unpredictable nature the SCP Foundation
has resolved to just leave her be
because she can't be captured the SCP
Foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that she creates
she is a class 4 reality warper capable
of constructing wonderful fantastic
objects and them with anomalous
properties she's famous and widely
beloved for using this ability to create
bizarre magical and not even a little
bit dangerous toys games candies soft
drinks and other products aimed at
everyone from ages 9 to 99 these
products are distributed by as yet
unknown means many of wain's Creations
are in Foundation possession such as SCP
3551 the awesome inflatable Alien
Invaders and SCP 2514 a lovely home who
can sing Happy
Birthday how Grand Wonder tainment
inherited the Wonder tainment name from
her father who either passed away or
never existed at all the circumstances
of his death and perhaps non-existence
were very messy involving a mass
murderer the leader of a shadowy
international extra governmental
paramilitary organization at least one
deity and four bent paperclips she owns
Six corgis and all of them are named
Jeremy in a free time she likes
to
no no this is all still wrong all right
enough is enough you want to know who Dr
Wonder tainment really is well you asked
for it Dr Wonder tainment is the name
given to SCP
001 who due to his deity level power has
been classed as apolon by the foundation
there is no possible way to contain him
he is a class five reality warper
capable of breaking down and
reconstructing the very laws of reality
did you really think that those little
trinkets were the full extent of my I
mean his Creations did you truly think
of him as such a small Petty creature Dr
Wonder tainment is no mere toy Smith no
he is a god want examples of his
Creations just look around you
everything from the most innocent safe
class to the most harrowing ker class
it's all thanks to him he is behind
everything Marshall Carter and dark the
sarst the Church of the broken God even
the Scarlet King himself all that time
all that effort all it came down to was
one entity One Singular living
personification of chaos one day the SCP
Foundation will finally give up trying
to find out how he distributes his
products when they will finally see how
small and worthless their attempts to
restore order really are and they will
be driven before his power they will
crumble and Decay into nothingness you
will bow before Dr
wondertainment had you going for a
second there didn't we you should have
seen the looks on your faces but let's
start again one more time
we're being serious this time mask off
here's the true story of Dr Wonder
tainment Dr Wonder tainment is the name
given to SCP 001 who due to his
relatively benign Nature has been
classed as neutralized by the foundation
rather than focusing on containing
Wonder tainment himself the SCP
Foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that he creates
he is a reality warper whose limits have
yet to be documented capable of
constructing other normal objects and
imbuing them with anomalous properties
he's become infamous for using this
ability to create bizarre magical and
potentially dangerous toys and games
that are distributed by as yet unknown
means due to his secretive nature almost
nothing is known of Dr Wonder tain's
true Origins and the waters have been
muddied extensively by the side effects
of his reality warping ability in fact
it's entirely possible that Dr Wonder
tainment himself doesn't know who he is
anymore it's possible that all the
proposed Origins and descriptions of Dr
Wonder tainment are true in their own
way but it is equally possible that none
of them are all that's known for sure is
that do Wonder tainment be they male or
female Corporation or single individual
is a constant thorn in the SCP
Foundation side no matter who they
really are they're not going away soon
and only time will tell who they'll be
tomorrow or what further Horrors they
and their company will create and that's
where our story will have to come to an
end at least for now we hope you enjoyed
it and remember keep believing the
military helicopter sailed through the
skies at a steady Pace its destination
somewhere in Southwest Asia along one of
the many points where the legendary
Euphrates and Tigress rivers meet
depending on the outcome this mission
may have changed the the course of the
SCP Foundation and its activities
forever or it might do nothing at all
such was often the way when it came to
dealing with the unpredictable and the
anomalous inside the helicopter Dr Anton
zarov was practically rattling with
nervous excitement ever since he'd been
assigned to the 682 termination detail
after years of wasting away in an
archival desk job he'd seen the kind of
anomalies you wouldn't believe 173 that
nightmare statue that snaps the necks of
anyone who dared to look away from it
811 the strange and also strangely
adorable swamp woman whose costic mucus
could reliably melt seemingly any
organic matter save of course 682 itself
and Dr zov was particularly astonished
by the aftermath of the epic battle
between 096 and 682 which left both of
these indestructible monsters horribly
maimed but all of that it was nothing
compared to what they were we're going
to witness today Dr zarov muttered a
prayer to himself in frightened
reverence Dr cleff Who was sitting
across from him in the helicopter wasn't
quite as wound up like some action movie
cliche made manifest he sliced chunks
from a plump red apple with a Bowie
knife and sucked the pieces off the
blade clef found zarov nervousness
little more than amusing first time at
sight zero rookie clef asked between
apple slices Dr zarov nodded forcing a
Meek smile clef just chuckled
you're wasting your time you know C said
everyone takes a shot at the reptile I
fa it down myself once mono imano and
during that moment I realized something
as much as it pains me to ever throw in
the towel we're not going to kill this
thing it's just a budget snc of course
these kinds of doubts had crossed Dr
zarov mind before he'd watch countless
termination attempts organized by far
more senior researchers than himself
fail and fail embarrassingly something
about signing your name up for 682
termination was like tying on a
blindfold grabbing a bat and stepping up
to a Piata except in this case the
pinata isn't wearing a blindfold and
somehow it can hit you back it is a
one-way ticket to professional
humiliation and if you're unlucky enough
to get too close when things go south it
can be so much worse but Dr zarov well
and truly believe that he would be the
exception to so much miserable failure
after all this was an idea nobody had
tried before an announcement over the
intercom signaled that they had now
entered site zero airspace they'd be
landing shortly and just like that Dr
zarov was all raised hairs and Goose
flesh once again it seemed like such a
hazy distant miracle that his project
proposal would even get majority
approval from the 05 Council and now he
was about to touch down and actually see
it naturally Dr kleff noticed Dr zarov
emotional cues and like so many
playground bullies decided to seize on
it don't buy into the hype Dr kleff said
it's really not that special the
helicopter touched down Dr zarov felt
defensive he was almost tempted to use
hard words but he realized from Dr
clef's mischievous smile that perhaps
that was always the intention he
certainly had a reputation if one were
to put it in the most neutral terms
possible but this was your 001 proposal
Dr Cliff zarov countered I would have
thought you'd be more invested in this
Dr KF Rose to his feet and sheathed his
Bowie knife as the helicopter's side
door opened he gestured for Dr zarov to
get up and follow him before saying
believe me even a giant flaming demigod
loses its luster when you need to write
enough of those stupid reports on it the
two researchers disembarked from the
helicopter and walked into the legendary
containment facility site zero one of
the most important and secretive contain
containment sites out there even by the
standards of the ever clandestine SCP
Foundation if ever containment
procedures failed here they'd be staring
down the barrel of an unprecedented
situation A Patmos XK Class end of the
world scenario after all they were
dealing with one of the most serious and
Powerful anomalies they'd ever contained
here cleen zarov entered the control
room filled with huge monitors
displaying every kind of recordable
metric but the largest screens were do
ated by long range Drone footage of the
iconic anomaly they were all there to
see SCP 001 perhaps better known as
Uriel the gate Guardian while Dr klef
remained unfazed Dr zarov felt a single
tear crawling down his cheek he had
never seen an entity so utterly a
inspiring an impossibly tall glowing
humanoid entity with eight great fiery
wings and a glowing blade made of pure
Heavenly Fire every bit as hot as the
sun to think that such an incredible
creature existed on the same Earth as
him made him feel so incredibly small
the theories as to the creature's true
nature were as Myriad as they were
unknowable some of the more devout among
the foundations's ranks even believe
that he is a direct servant of the
abrahamic god guarding the gate to
Paradise the Garden of Eden Heaven
itself Dr clef just
laughed everything you'd hope it' be
zarov he said Dr zarov nodded more cff
and more even from such a distance the
raw power of the gate Guardian is
impossible to ignore it radiates off of
the being like an invisible Aura Dr
zarov had read all the files to get
within a kilometer of the mighty entity
would be to court death anyone who
approached it would taste the heat of
its sword cleave them apart at the
atomic level and effectively erasing
them from existence it's about as dead
as anyone could possibly be save for
someone being thrown into SC P 3930 and
literally removed from the plane of
existence SCP 3930 had failed to
annihilate the hard to destroy reptile
but perhaps where that whole lot of
nothing had failed the gate Guardian
would succeed it remained floating fixed
on one place as though waiting for
something but what perhaps a fateful
confrontation with a certain reptilian
nightmare Dr zarov hoped like many he
had heard the most famous story
involving SC C p001 the gate Guardian
which took place before even the days of
the SCP Foundation after all every
Foundation needs a Founder doesn't it
and that's how it began the founder was
a mysterious figure no matter who you
ask some say it was 05 D1 others say it
was the legendary administrator some
even believe that it was someone else
someone older someone who predated even
the current 05 Council and administrator
a wise and learn figure here going on a
pilgrimage around the Known World in
hopes of expanding their perspective and
seeking out the strange and unusual it
was traveling down the river Tigress
that the founder encountered the gate
guardian of course as always from a mile
away the founder saw the distant glowing
Point shaped like a human being with
wings it was unlike anything they'd ever
borne witness to that's when the founder
felt a door open in the back of their
mind and something sneak in a single
word projecting somehow infinite
Authority
prepare the very presence of the word
made the Founder's body rattle never had
they heard such a voice conveying such
certainty and power it had to be the
voice of the distant glowing figure it
couldn't be anything else could it much
like Dr zarov would experience hundreds
of years later the founder even as a
person so powerful knowledgeable and
influential suddenly felt so
unimaginably small the founder became a
aware of not just the extent of the
world around them or even the universe
but a terrifying Multiverse of
possibilities there was light out there
of course but even more darkness and
terrifying things were hiding in the
dark is that what prepare me did it mean
to be ready for all the Terrible Things
hiding in the dark just waiting for the
opportunity to strike just how great was
the extent of the things Humanity didn't
understand out there the Founder's mind
was flooded with so many possib
abilities if there was a tide of
monsters in the Blackness that needed to
be fought back it was too much for any
one person to ever handle the founder
needed a group all gathered around the
same mission to contain the coming
threat that the great glowing being had
warned them about people of focus
commitment and sheer willpower people
who would accept the knowledge of the
Terrible Things in the darkness and
still not waver in the face of their
great and Noble challenge people who if
necessary would be willing to die in the
dark so that the rest of the human race
would live in the light they would be
Humanity's greatest Defenders even
though they would defend in secret this
was how it had all begun supposedly Dr
zarov had heard the story whispered many
times while conducting his research into
SCP 001 and now here he stood perhaps
where the founder had been standing all
those years ago the SCP Foundation had
faed down greater threats than SCP 682
the hanged King the sealed King The
Scarlet King now if they wanted to they
could go toe-to-toe with the Burger King
and all of that had begun with a single
word from the mighty gate Guardian
surely an ordinary overgrown lizard
wouldn't be too much for it to handle
but of course they hadn't just come here
to look at the gate Guardian that'd be
an egregious waste of time and
helicopter fuel they'd come here
transporting precious car cargo a chunk
of SCP 682s flesh cut from the Beast
itself currently it was attached to yet
another remote controll drone set on a
collision course for the gate Guardian
Dr zarov watched the video feeds with
sweaty Palms as he saw the Drone and its
diabolical cargo enter the video's View
getting closer to the gate Guardian by
the moment Closer Closer until the gate
Guardian struck out with its great and
terrible sword for such an
astronomically huge being to move so
incredibly fast was astounding in and of
itself but what Dr zarov found even more
exciting was the result in one quick
slash of its solar blade both the Drone
and the SCP 682 tissue sample were
utterly evaporated gone reduced to less
than even Ash Dr zarov face split into a
manine if it could destroy the tissue
sample then surely it could destroy the
monster itself and what a glorious day
that would be Meanwhile Back At The
Cross testing chambers of site 19 SCP
682 was having another miserable day it
was dragged half melted out of its acid
tank at 3:00 a.m. in the morning and
left slowly regenerating on the floor a
typical SCP Foundation wakeup call it
thought to itself with the role of its
still regenerating eyes what form of
horrible torment would be in store for
it this time it began scrolling through
its mental Rolodex for the most recent
but painful termination attempts oh yes
of course they tried Suffocation via
vacuum that definitely made s SCP 682
feel a little lightheaded at least until
of course it adapted its body to begin
releasing a gas of similar composition
to its native atmosphere which had
certainly given those white-coated
wearing ssts a lot to take note about
then how could it forget they tried
roasting it to death with extremely high
temperatures thankfully as always it had
a trick up its sleeve adapting a carrase
made of solid helium to defend it from
the fire then shattering it to shred a
bunch of those buffoons in the orange
jumpsuits then they'd cut off a sample
of its flesh shoved it into some absurd
industrial blender before shoving what's
left into a centerfuse what a Divine
pleasure it had been for 682 to hear the
explosion down the hall when the
antimatter embedded in its genes went
off and put a number of those idiotic
Foundation drones in the hospital for
months serves them right to continually
meddling in the matters of forces they
couldn't even hope to understand and
today they were feeding at the carcass
of a dead cow SCP 682 side it felt
sometimes that the adults testing it had
forgotten the note reading highly
intelligent on its file being dragged
into one of those Gastly Chambers and
given some form of Novel stimulus could
only mean one thing something stupid and
painful was going to happen said stupid
painful thing in this case was that the
cow was spiked with an instance of SCP
3521 also known as the banana Pill by D
What followed was a remarkably absurd
instance even by SCP 682 cross test
standards where a huge number of bananas
spontaneously burst out of 682s body
being a big fan of bananas apparently
682 was actually able to eat and
metabolize the bananas faster than the
anomalous banana Pill by dto could
produce them and because bananas are
each individually slightly Radioactive
active 682 was able to synthesize this
Collective radiation into a powerful
death ray that it used to cause a great
deal of death and destruction as far as
Dr zarov and the rest of the SCP
Foundation were concerned this thing
being cleaved apart on an atomic level
by the gate Guardian couldn't come soon
enough sometimes it took the ultimate
Knight to slay the Ultimate Dragon not
long after that SCP 682 was dosed up on
enough sedatives to give New York City a
weekl long nap and carded over to site
zero on a heavily secured armored Convoy
taking SC SCP 682 this far between
containment sites was considered a
matter of grave seriousness in other
words the result of this little
experiment better have been good to
justify the insane security risk it took
to even get the damn lizard out here Dr
zarov and Dr kleff decided to
co-supervise the Cross test from the
safety of the sight zero observation
deck either would have been foolish to
want to get any closer even Dr kle while
undeniably a loose cannon didn't have an
outright Death Wish unless of course
wishing death on SCP 682 would count 682
sedated body was strapped to a large
unmanned vehicle the kind they might use
for an exploratory mission on another
planet and sent in the direction of the
gate guardian's deadly proximal Zone a
secondary camera drone was also sent in
to lag behind correctly predicting that
when the gate Guardian struck SCP 682 it
would oblit late the unmanned vehicle
too and whatever happened out there the
foundation needed it on camera Dr zarov
had sweaty palms and gritted teeth
seeing the culmination of his
professional career unfold in front of
him Dr cleff was looking at a meme on
his phone as 682 got closer it began
hearing a booming voice in its head just
like the founder had so long ago the
voice simply said one word over and over
getting louder as the unmanned vehicle
brought the two Titans closer and closer
and closer
die 682 still feeling groggy thought oh
if it only were so simple and then it
happened SCP 682 entered the dreaded 1
km range the guardian slashed down with
its mighty sword creating a brilliant
flash of light in the aftermath the
unmanned vehicle was obliterated and 682
was left heavily injured on the ground
still trying to process what had just
happened 682 looked up sobered by the
pain and saw the being that had dealt
this blow 682 began to sneer is this
meant to be the garden it said before
breaking into a venomous
laugh this is not the garden the garden
is far west of here the gate Guardian
struck again with its flaming blade once
again projecting that single word die
die die die die
When the Smoke cleared 682 was even more
horrifically injured with only one limb
left but still Against All Odds alive it
used the one limb to drag itself towards
the gate Guardian fueled by pure rage
and spite die you command me to die oh
wouldn't we all like that but this is my
curse for suggesting the fruit the
reptile growled back at the base Dr arov
was mortified how could it possibly be
surviving all this the sword was meant
to cleave apart its victims on an atomic
level Atomic it's in freaking Adams
godamn it Dr zarov wish he had a paper
bag to breathe into Dr KF showing an
uncharacteristic degree of compassion
patted zarov on the back saying it's
okay buddy we all remember our first
time back at the center of the action
the gate Guardian blasted 682 with its
solar blade again somehow despite the
terrifying power wielded by the guardian
682 continued to live it was alive
barely but after three strikes from The
Sword to be alive with whatever the evil
version of a miracle would be this is
not the garden and you are not yuel 682
roared before spitting at the gate
Guardian
Pretender one more violent strike from
the gate guardian and 682 finally
collapsed unconscious from the extent of
its pain pain and its injuries but
despite all of Dr zov's hopes the gate
Guardian did not strike a killing blow
on the unconscious Beast instead it
transmitted another word another order
impossible for any human being to ignore
remove as though in a trance the workers
of site zero including Dr zarov and Dr
kleff entered the Forbidden 1 km
exclusion Zone the gate Guardian allowed
them safe passage as they used tools and
vehicles to pick up the heavily injured
SCP 682 and card it away from the gate
Guardians feet after they all came back
to their senses Dr zarov simply said
what just happened Dr cleff just
Shrugged I've learned to stop
questioning it what is the most
dangerous creature in the universe here
on planet Earth there are creatures that
have hardly evolved since prehistoric
eras like sharks crocodiles and snakes
perfect biological killing machines but
then again the the animal kingdom is
nothing when compared to the Minag array
of creatures contained by the SCP
Foundation so once again what is the
most dangerous creature in the universe
is it SCP 682 the damage regenerating
reptile with a hatred for all other
forms of life or is it the Scarlet king
or is the broken God more deserving of
that title maybe the answer still lies
elsewhere and thankfully there is one
SCP in the foundation's archives that
might not be the most dangerous itself
but teaches us a very important lesson
about what the most dangerous entity
truly is this is the story of SCP 001
the spiral path an important distinction
before we go any further SCP 001 doesn't
refer to a single creature object or
entity but rather a collection of
various anomalies contained by the SCP
Foundation it is unclear why there are
multiple files collected under the
shared designation of SCP 001 some
believe these anomalies are some of the
earliest ever contained by the
foundation encountered before they
introduce their current numbering system
there is also the theory that this is
intentional misdirection that the
multiple SCP 001 files are an attempt by
the foundation to conceal secret
information about the true SCP 001
anomaly sharing the name SCP 001 include
the infamous affir mention Scarlet King
a powerful Aldrich being intent on
ending all creation another anomalous
being with similar levels of destructive
power is the gate Guardian believed to
be an angel standing at the entrance to
the Garden of Eden it too goes by the
name SCP 001 but for the purposes of
this video we will be using SCP 001 to
refer to something otherwise codenamed
the spiral path and while it is not a
creature in and of itself SCP 001 does
yield one answer to that important
question what is the most dangerous
creature in the universe on paper SCP
001 does not seem to be much and it
certainly doesn't appear to be any sort
of threat as its nickname suggests the
spiral path is exactly that located deep
in a wooded area known only as site zero
SCP 001 is a gravel path in the shape of
a spiral your first thought at hearing
that might be what could be so important
about a path if some someone were to
find themselves walking along the spiral
path traveling clockwise around the
gravel then they will find that nothing
happens it's just a normal path with
slight inclines and declines as one
traverses it if one should walk
counterclockwise around it though then
they will begin to experience SCP 001's
first anomalous effect the path will
begin to feel as if it is sloping uphill
getting steeper and steeper when they
reach the beginning of the path again a
person will still feel as if they're
walking endlessly uphill all the while
the path itself does not move or change
in form or altitude to put it simply
walking one way around SCP 001 causes it
to behave normally walking the other the
path does not adhere to the laws of
physics you may well be thinking is that
all on a surface level the spiral path
does appear to just be an unmoving low
threat anomaly while it may not be as
aggressive or malicious as some of the
SCP Foundation Rogues Gallery it is
still a spatial anomaly that defies all
ukian geometry that might sound like
small potatoes when compared to
everything the SCP Foundation has faced
over the years but bear in mind if the
spiral path is truly SCP 001 and the
very first anomaly that the foundation
learned of then a simple path that
ignores the ordinary laws of space and
time would have been a major Discovery
in the organization's earliest days but
why would they still keep the spiral
path so heavily guarded all these years
later SCP 001 is kept behind a maximum
security fence that has been constructed
all the way around the perimeter of site
zero at all times the SCP Foundation
keeps no less than five fully armed
members of security Personnel on site to
keep watch over the spiral path and to
make sure that no one approaches it who
isn't authorized to there is a small
metal plaque too bearing an unknown
inscription on it special containment
procedures for SCP 001 state that this
plaque is to be kept in good condition
and it should be immediately reported if
it shows any signs of damage a
foundation Physics laboratory is also
located nearby where research staff
tirelessly conducts scientific tests on
SCP 001 and its anomalous properties so
there's definitely something more to the
spiral path than a simple stroll around
it would tell you attached to SCP 001's
file is an item referred to as document
001 05 written by high-ranking
Foundation researcher Dr Everett man any
prospective or new members of the 05
Council are required to read this
document and from the events it details
learn the truth not just about the truth
of the Spiral path but the truth about
the SCP Foundation itself Dr man begins
this file by explaining to the reader
that either he or one of the original
founders of the SCP Foundation must have
died and the person reading has been
appointed as a essor whether his death
was caused by an SCP an operative from
another anomalous organization like the
global occult Coalition or getting a
little close to the flame man states
that old age definitely wouldn't be what
killed him he writes we took care of
that didn't we whether he means that he
and the rest of the Old Guard are
somehow Immortal or just working for the
foundation would likely mean dying
before reaching old age is unclear but
Dr man's next statement is one that
changes the very way we view the
foundation and its entire purpose we
have never discovered an SCP in the
entire history of the foundation
according to document
0015 every instance of an anomalous
creature entity or object is entirely
staged he then goes on to describe Aaron
seagull A Gifted physicist that Dr man
regarded very highly I believe his name
would be there with Edison Einstein and
Hawking I knew him very well he was and
may still be my brother the pair
evidently shared a close personal
connection and it was seagull who first
discovered SCP 001 during a hike Aaron
stumbled upon the spiral path noticing
that no matter how far up hill he seemed
to travel his elevation never once
changed only for him to end up back at
the start of the path being a physicist
seagull quickly realized how this
unassuming gravel path did not conform
to ukian Geometry that it did not fit
within the laws of nature constructing a
small wooden Shack nearby Aaron seagull
began to study the properties of the
Spiral path equation after equation
hours spent examining every variable and
experimenting with his findings until
something unforeseen happened Aaron
created an SCP a key that had the innate
ability to open any lock nowadays that
same key is still in The foundation's
Possession under the designation SCP
005 slowly Aaron began to bring other
into the fold trusted colleagues and
other scientific Minds among them was of
course Dr Everett man who was still a
medical student at Harvard at the time
this Brain Trust a think tank composed
of only a select few they were the very
beginning the ones who founded the SCP
Foundation using their own fortunes and
funding from Thomas Carter the group
continued with seagull's experiments the
scientists had high hopes for what they
could achieve planning to change the
world for the better feeding the hungry
providing shelter to the homeless curing
the sick and even cheating death itself
in the beginning this Proto Foundation
started small their goals were Noble but
could not realistically be achieved
overnight they try to make items that
would improve life such as a fountain of
youth a partially sentient Civil War
statue and an extremely bouncy ball
better known to the foundation today as
SCP 006 SCP 011 and SCP 018 respectively
but then this New Foundation began to
grow with more organization and a secret
facility and with that expansion came
emboldened scientists eager to change
the world the group began working on
human test subjects volunteers and
Drifters that soon became scps the
spiral path was not just a break in the
fabric of reality in a metaphorical
sense it referred to the spiraling path
the newly formed Foundation itself was
on every Discovery they made led to to
another and that to another still until
things started to go wrong during the
continuing experiments Dr Man created
SCP 008 a deadly Zombie Plague capable
of infecting anyone with 100% lethality
more and more of the founders were so
invested in their projects that the
results were often nightmarish the
foundation needed help that came when
Thomas Carter showed their work to the
military in exchange for additional
funding and personnel the SCP Foundation
expanded even further becoming an
international organization and bringing
in new researchers and staff in some
instances the founders would arrange for
the anomalies they had created to be
found by the new recruits other times
they would fabricate reports changing
the details of how things like SCP 008
or the Fountain of Youth were first
discovered anything the founders said
was simply now a fact no one questioned
them even then problems still arose
founding members broke away from the SCP
Foundation some even creating Splinter
groups that would later become infamous
groups of Interest the foundation's
directive shifted now focusing on the
containment of anomalies as yet more
were created through darker means SCP
231 was taken from an orphanage Dr man
himself vivisected a small boy who then
became SCP 610 the flesh that hates and
there were more still Abel the blood
Pond and even the hard to destroy
reptile all of them were the creation of
the foundation itself but through it all
Dr man wrote he was never afraid of the
path that the foundation was on he was
never even afraid of all the monsters
and Abominations that he and the other
Founders had secretly created by
studying SCP 001 what truly scared him
were the anomalies the foundation didn't
create there were some that would just
appear in containment one day even if
they hadn't been there before before
they would seem like they had always
been there Dr man closes document
0015 with the realization that he and
the other Founders simply were not in
control anymore the tale of Dr man and
the other founders of the SCP Foundation
is one of noble intentions that
ultimately became corrupted at first the
founders created scps that they hoped
would benefit Humanity but then came the
mistakes the accidents the monsters like
SCP P 008 SCP 610 and even SCP
682 the foundation lied to the
governments and militaries of the world
claiming they'd found these scps not
created them and in return they received
funding and staff to expand allowing the
SCP Foundation to grow to become what it
is today Dr man posits that at this
point the foundation was no longer in
control but perhaps they never were and
olve this stems back from One Singular
starting point the spiral path it might
be impossible to truly know how many
anomalies and scps the foundation
created just from researching SCP 001
only the 05 Council will ever know
exactly how many of the founders
discoveries they themselves were
responsible for and now you know the
answer to what's the most dangerous
creature in the universe its regular
people dabbling with something they
could never hope to fully understand
starting with the hope to change the
world only to create monsters that might
one day destroy it the sun's gone bad
people and animals are melting
everywhere the world is coming to an end
and there's nothing I can do about it
will I'll be able to find food while
I'll be able to defeat or avoid the
horrific flesh monsters all around me or
the desperate and hungry survivors left
in this terrible New World keep watching
and find out can I survive 100 days in
SCP 001 when day breaks hey folks it's
it's your boy Kyle you probably know me
more for gaming videos than post
apocalyptic Vlogs but hey I'm a
versatile guy and I think I might go
insane from the fear if I don't talk to
somebody about all this craziness if
you're live and seeing this right now
well congratulations you're probably
doing a lot better than most people here
if you call them people now but if
you're seeing this a few years in the
future like I don't know you woke up
from a 10-year coma like Rick from The
Walking Dead and you're wondering what
the hell happened to planet Earth this
video is probably going to answer a lot
of your questions first things first
whatever you do you've got to stay away
from the Sun it touches you for even a
second you're dead or Worse welcome to
day one of the end of the world for all
of you who are still in a solid state of
matter you're probably wondering how I'm
still alive too chances are it's for the
exact same reason you are sheer dumb
luck I was down here my gaming basement
when day broke just level grinding when
my TV got taken over by those SCP
Foundation people telling us that the
the sun's gone evil for whatever reason
and now we've all got to stay inside
hell if I was up there making myself a
sandwich or grabbing another can of
Mountain Dew I'd be a freaking puddle
right now it's funny my mom always told
me spending all day indoors was bad for
me I'll have to mention that to her if
she's alive point is the world has gone
to Hell in a hand basket and now I've
got only one objective survive I'm going
to see if I can survive the horrifying
post-apocalyptic world of when day
breaks for this first day I'm just going
going to hunker down I kind of hope this
is just a dream day two all right I'm up
in atam baby sadly I can now report that
this isn't a dream this really is our
horrible new reality it's the sun's
world and we're just living in it I've
been spending the last several hours
just waiting for Nightfall outside
Against All Odds the internet and the
power grid haven't gone down yet guess
what's ever wrong with the sun only
affects people and animals not objects
thank heaven for small mercies right
people on Twitter have been live posting
their situations out there sharing
advice on how we might all be able to
stay out of the Sun and survive this
whole crazy thing and hey unless they're
dead or full of hot air maybe those SCP
Foundation people know something about
what's going on here if we really can
get to their buildings maybe we can
figure out how to reverse all this mess
maybe for now I'm just going to focus on
staying alive hopefully Night hits soon
I really need to use the bathroom oh boy
it's day three and new issues are
starting to pop up I've been heading
upstairs to go to the bathroom but while
I don't want to be crude I'm running low
on toilet paper and it's um starting to
become a problem I ran out of my last
roll a few days ago and now I'm starting
to go to my bookshelves I have a few
newspapers left that I tore up and used
for toilet paper first um they weren't
exactly comfortable but hey you need to
make do but without toilet paper and
without newspapers I need to figure out
what my favorite and least favorite
books are I'm starting with the prefaces
of all the books seeing as I don't
generally need to reread them you know
they're Expendable you know a lot of
these books I haven't read since I was
like 15 so maybe those will be the ones
I can't make up my mind on whether I'm
going to use the Harry Potter books or
the Percy Jackson and The Olympian books
first uh let me know what you think in
the comments I guess I need to go to the
bathroom day four and now I'm trying to
figure out how to pass the time as you
already know I'm an avowed lifelong
gamer so while the electricity and the
internet still work I'm going to keep
gaming to pass the time and keep my all
too precious sanity I still have no
intention of going out there even at
night but it's left me feeling kind of
stir crazy I want to walk around the
city again I want to go for a drive and
feel the breeze in my hair but seeing as
I can't do that without experiencing a
truly horrifying transformation I've
been spending a lot of time on GTA 5
online gu we'll never get GTA 6 now what
a bummer still these last few days it's
felt more like Los Santos has been my
home than where I actually live there
were even a few other people on the
server I don't know about you but I take
some comfort in that hey folks I'm back
thankfully welcome to day five we've
still got electricity thankfully hence
why you can still see this I haven't
heard anything from my family and I
don't want to assume the worst but it's
probably just best not to think about it
I've been heading up and downstairs to
grab have more food at night you're
probably wondering but Kyle why don't
you bring it all downstairs to save
going up all together which I'd say I
don't have a fridge downstairs smartass
but I'm starting to realize food is
going to be a real issue here it's kind
of stupid now that I think about it in
all the zombie movies and TV shows I
used to watch it was all bullets and
baseball bats killing your way through
all those Undead Freaks and worrying
about the rest later guess they don't
want you to think about how you're only
going going to ever be a couple weeks
away from starvation kind of ruins the
badass post-apocalyptic power fantasy I
only have a couple days worth of food
left here and after that I'm going to
need to go out and search for more or
I'm going to need to relocate I don't
feel comfortable here anymore you know
early on I thought when you got exposed
to the sunlight it just killed you but
no it's worse you keep living you're
just changed into one of those things
these last few days I've looked out the
windows when I've come up at night for
food I I see them sometimes slithering
in the yard or down the street these
things that used to be people I wonder
if they're people that I knew once
before all this and I tried to shove the
thought out of my mind freaking myself
out about all this doesn't help I know
that much just keep thinking about how
do they move this like weird kind of
purpose like they're searching for
something but what could they be
searching for I'm just going to go and
get more food we'll speak again soon
stay safe whoever you are welcome to day
six it's night time now and I'm heading
out for the first time I keep seeing
these weird slimy creatures everywhere
and they make me kind of sick to look at
them but I try my best to just keep
moving I'm on a mission tonight I'm
going to go to the local supermarket and
check to see if there's still food there
while also grabbing myself a quick snack
I'm going to keep this one brief I don't
want to do a full shopping spree tonight
and it's already too late just need to
know the food is there I decided earlier
in the night if I survive this thing and
the getting is good at the bargain Mark
I'll make my way back tomorrow for
something a little more you know
substantial after all the fewer trips I
make out the safer I'm likely to be by
the time I made it to the supermarket
though while I was practically a nervous
wreck from the fear of turning into one
of those things I made an amazing
Discovery while the windows were broken
and the floor was a mess most of the
food was still there day seven or should
I say night 7 galvanized by My Success
from the previous days I decided to come
back back to the supermarket with a
shopping cart I wanted to get enough
food for at least a week so I wouldn't
need to come back out again hey maybe
I'm not so bad at this whole apocalypse
thing after all I grabbed plenty of
canned food from the supermarket most of
the perishables had already gone moldy
by the time I showed up so fresh fruit
was out of the question suddenly I
started getting scared about the thought
of scurvy but pushed it quickly from my
mind I'd cross that bridge when I got to
it hey hey it's day eight and I'm still
kicking that's got to count for
something right I started taking more
trips out at night time just to stretch
my legs and keep the blood flowing when
the slithering things that were once
people past me I just make myself scarce
and hide in the shadows you know I I
hear them muttering sometimes and like
this melted Voice or voices it's
unsettling but it's amazing what you'll
get used to in just over a week it's e
to see all these streets without people
in them I know that I should probably
just stay inside but I I really can't I
don't know if this will ever just stop
and if it doesn't I I don't want to
spend my last days cooped up in my own
basement day nine you know there are
some benefits to being in the
post-apocalypse to ever so slightly
offset all the utterly crushing
downsides while during the day we're all
prisoners of the Sun in our own homes at
night we can do whatever the hell we
want I took a baseball bat that I keep
in my closet and went to the local
furniture store I smashed up every
single vase and all the windows like one
of those rage rooms because nobody could
stop me then afterwards I went straight
to the local computer and gaming store
and took all the Alienware Tech I could
physically carry you know there's no
value in money anymore if you want
something you can just go and take it
every cloud has a silver lining day 10
more GTA 5 today I decided to get on my
headset and speak to a few others who
were still around and on the servers you
know it was so nice to speak to other
human beings for once they came from all
over the world and were dealing with the
same evil Sun Insanity as me you have no
idea how incredibly valuable it is to
find people to talk to in a time like
this the other players had plenty of
theories as to why all this had happened
some thought it was some kind of mutant
solar flare they remembered reading
about on some conspiracy form back in
the day others speculated it was the
result of some weapon created by the us
or Russian or Chinese military that gone
wrong one person said that maybe it was
a punishment from God like maybe on some
level we all deserved it you know things
got pretty quiet after that day 11 I've
been having the most terrible nightmares
lately it's probably just a product of
all the stress I've been under lately
but in the nightmares I'm running down a
dark Street being chased by those flesh
creatures I'm moving fast but they're
moving way faster they're whispering to
me but I can't make out anything they're
saying this morning which is to say
evening I woke up screaming and drenched
in sweat I can't really explain why but
I feel like something terrible is going
to happen soon okay okay I'm alive
that's enough isn't it and if you're
watching this I assume you're live too
congratulations welcome to the nightmare
space between day 11 and day 27 sorry
that I haven't been in in contact for so
long as you can see I'm not at home
anymore you couldn't pay me to go back
there not that money is worth anything
anymore A lot's happened since I last
made one of these and I wish I could
tell you any of it was good H I wish I
could forget it all but the things I've
seen and heard I don't think they're
ever going to leave my head no matter
what I do I thought about making another
entry now and then but I always found a
reason to put it off it's remarkable how
your other priorities fall away when
you're just thinking about where your
next meal is coming from it just kind of
puts everything into perspective of
course during my travels I saw more of
those freaks slithering around sorry
sorry I I know I shouldn't call them
that it's kind of a coping mechanism you
know it all gets a lot harder when you
have to think of them as X people that's
another thing all these goofy zombie
shows got wrong it's a lot harder to
separate what they were from what they
are now especially when you know these
were your friends your neighbors your
well I can't avoid talking about it
forever can I I stuffed my backpack with
whatever I could grab and left my home
two nights ago it wasn't just because I
was going stir crazy back there though I
admit that didn't exactly help it was
what happened there I just came back
from a food run put most of it in the
fridge then retired back down into the
basement to enjoy a late night snack and
do a little gaming to keep myself sane
I've been doing everything I could to
reverse my circadian rhythms and sleep
during the day just so I could be fully
operational during the 12-hour period
that going out side wouldn't melt me but
just like all those stories they told us
when we were kids there are monsters out
there at night and they are looking
before us when I first heard the sound I
was I wondered if it was something in
game or maybe dripping from a leaky pipe
but no it was too close to be fake and
too viscous to be water that's when I
looked at the door and saw this awful
pink slime slithering its way underneath
my door it was one of those things those
ex people trying to get in that'd be bad
enough but then it started talking to me
Kyle my darling why are you all cooped
up down here it isn't healthy you ought
to come outside sweetie get some Son my
darling it was my mom well it used to be
guess she wanted to come over and visit
me needless to say I got out of there
and I've got no intention of going back
that place is dead to me now I don't
even want to think about that voice ever
again both her and so not her so now I'm
on the move guess I'll speak to you
again when I stop stay safe out there
day 28 I decided it was best to make my
way out of town towards the fringes the
day first broke the people who were in
the most densely populated areas were
the first to go that's why I decided to
haul up in a gas station last night just
to avoid the Sun but during the night
people came not ex people actual people
they showed up in a jeep outside the
building refueled and then came in they
were wearing black cobbled together
outfits and hockey masks they were all
either carrying bats or axes too you can
probably understand why I didn't decide
to introduce myself when they busted
their way in I concealed myself in a
broom closet while they searched around
it was nerve shredding I'd never been
more thankful in my life when they left
day 29 coming up on a month of this
madness after the incident at the gas
station I realized I needed some kind of
Defense it's not just the Sun and those
creatures I need to worry about just
like the old world people could be
dangerous here too that's why I snuck
into a gun store in the dead of night
some of it had been looted but much like
the supermarket near my house there was
plenty still here the walls were covered
in all manner of rifles shotguns and
even submachine guns I heard somewhere
that revolvers are more reliable and
easy to maintain than other types so
since I'm a gun novice I grabbed a
revolver and stuffed my pockets with as
many bullets as I could carry let's hope
I never have to use any of them day 30
do I get to call this a month of
survival I mean if we're talking
February I'd be a month in already what
a horribly dubious honor that is I saw
something disgusting last night and I
thought I'd share it just to get it off
my mind last night as I was moving
through the Wilderness I saw a group of
other survivors gathered around a
campfire I remained scarce but
approached just to see what was going on
still carrying My Revolver just to be
safe but the people around the campfire
were eating something and when I saw
what they were eating I swear to God I
almost threw up they were chopping up
one of the X people cooking the parts
over the fire and eating it day 31 a
month by anyone's definition ever since
seeing those others eating one of the ex
people I've had trouble eating even
normal food myself my stomach aches and
my throat burns God I feel so weak I
keep laying down and resting I know I
need to eat soon if I want to survive to
day 32 but every time I think about
eating I think about the flesh of the ex
people sometimes I wish I hadn't
survived this long I'll eat soon I just
need to sleep first day
32-43 if you live this long you really
ought to be proud of yourself I've seen
thousands of those slimy ex people and
there's probably Millions more out there
well maybe even billions if we're being
honest with ourselves here am I just
talking into the void here is there even
anyone else out there who's human enough
to watch this stuff maybe I just need to
keep thinking about posterity on the off
chance that the world ever gets better
and we reach some time where children
are born again and all this Fades from
Human memory you'll still have these
stupid pointless little videos to
remember how awful all this was that way
at least I can make myself believe this
all had some kind of I don't know point
so what's happened with me not much
still moving at night surviving hiding
in closets and underground parking
complexes during daylight down to uh my
last few cans so I'm hoping to hit a
supermarket soon God what a ridiculous
way to go Starving in this new world
with so many new interesting ways to die
with the X people things have been a
little more eventful they're used to be
one blob to a person but they've started
joining up that's the best way I can put
it things that used to be people and
animals are starting to melt together
getting bigger and bigger they've never
been aggressive but I think it's best to
stay out of their way whatever all this
is about I am StreetWise enough to know
that it can't be anything good I'll just
keep moving and I hope you can do the
same whoever the hell you are hopefully
the next time I check in with you it's
with better news than this day 44 I saw
a shootout on the road last night the
people who are left the ones who are
still indeed people are becoming less
human something about situations like
this this sustained stress and pain and
hopeless less it weighs on you there are
no rules in the post-apocalypse the only
thing that can stop you from doing
anything is a Bullet to the Head five or
six people last night as afraid and
desperate and hungry as me gunned each
other down they did this for reasons I
will never understand even if I wanted
to because there are no survivors Left
To Tell the tale what a funny world we
live in day 45 I sleep when I can it's
surreal I remember when I feared the
dark and loved bright sunny days you all
this time in I still don't think I'm
used to the switch being flipped I've
been having awful dreams again I'm still
running in them with a deep red sun
shining up in the sky being chased by a
mountain of Flesh the size of Mount
Everest it's swallowing up the city
behind me and it keeps getting closer no
matter how fast I go I just I I can't
escape it'll get me eventually something
terrible is going to happen soon just
know it day 46 I shot a man today
I don't know if you survived I hope you
lived we encountered each other inside
an abandoned building I I think we
spooked each other and didn't have any
time to ask if we were friends or foes
we were too afraid either way we both
drew our weapons and I was faster than
he was when my revolver discharged and
he collapsed I ran off Sun would come up
in a few hours and I just needed to find
another place to hide what the hell have
I become I don't know how things could
get any worse than this not to self in
the future don't even dare to think how
could things get any worse because if
I've learned anything since this whole
nightmare started that is never a
rhetorical question welcome to the space
between day 47 and day 64 if you're
still alive and watching this I am so
sorry so I've got good news and I've got
bad news I'll give you the good news
first I've seen more people who haven't
been changed yet and the bad news last
time I saw them they were being dragged
out into the light kicking and screaming
in the tendrils of one of those horrible
flesh monsters I was telling you about
last time they've gotten a lot bigger
now and when I told you they weren't
aggressive well um yeah I I spoke a
little too soon I can't just sleep
during the day like I used to these
monsters and that's what they are now
they're monsters not people anymore they
Patrol they hunt they actively enter
buildings searching for hiding places
searching for people they can drag out
into the light
I've seen it with my own two eyes second
they're out they'll just start melting
and fusing with the mass making it even
bigger adding another voice to the
course and I hate myself cuz every time
I've seen it happen all I can think is
thank God that's not me God I wish I
could do something to help to save them
but that's not the world we live in the
second they touch the light it is
already over I wouldn't be helping
anyone by adding My Flesh to one of
those things I don't want them using my
body to get get to other people there's
only one thing I can do now keep moving
at night stay hidden get away from
population centers I've realized where I
need to go now I've still got a distant
memory of those broadcasts in the
earlier days of the event the SCP
Foundation I noted down coordinates to
the nearest facility they had on the
books and if I'm honest nearest is only
a relative term cuz at this rate it's
going to take me an eternity to get
there but it'll be worth it in the end
when I get there it all be worth it if I
can at least get some answers at least
know why the world turned into this hell
those SCP folks seem better prepared for
this than anyone so even if they can't
fix this they've at least got to have
answers right somebody needs to have
answers I really want to believe that
when the Sun goes down I'll start moving
again if you're watching this wish me
luck I don't have much food left I'll do
what I can yeah hey I realize I'm not
looking great right now but trust me you
should see the other guy day 65 to day
86 never thought I would make it this
far but hey life's just full of
surprises before you ask and I mean why
would you ask it's not like I can hear
you it wasn't one of the monsters that
did this to me it was another person
just like me desperate hungry afraid the
one difference between me and them was
the fact that they had a handgun and I
didn't they asked for all the food I had
and when I wasn't exactly forthcoming
they decided to shoot me and steal the
last of my food while I lay bleeding on
the ground oh well okay that's not
entirely Fair they did leave me with one
protein bar which I had to cave and eat
a couple days ago since then I've just
been forging what little food I can from
Plants along the way during my nighttime
walks but it isn't much and my wound is
giving me grief I sure hope they've got
doctors at this SCP Foundation or
otherwise ow I may be even more out of
luck than I thought here's the good news
for you since I know how much you love
that I'm not far off of the foundation
site now even in this state I'm probably
only a couple weeks away I think maybe I
can will myself to live that long at
least if I can get some answers just
before I die then I can be happy and
sometimes folks that's all you can ask
for final stretch let's hope I see you
again on the other end stay safe I'm
here I'm here the SCP Foundation on day
100 but I don't understand where is
everybody hello is anybody there God
damn it why is nobody here I I don't
understand they're meant to have the
answers they were meant to know what was
going on here but they're all gone too
it isn't fair it isn't fair is this it
is it all just over the end of the
freaking world as we know it it isn't
fair
it isn't fair it isn't fair wait are
those footsteps hello yes hello I'm over
here who's there oh my God what the hell
is that thing no no get away from me oh
God
disgusting now go check out when day
breaks scp096 and when day breaks SCP
049 for more Tales from the nightmarish
Universe of SCP 001 when day breaks